Kampen Sieger, du bist aber schnell.
Betreibst du etwa
Subbox Camping, wie auch immer man das
auf Twitch nennen mag.
Abofeed.
Abofeed, äh...
Gammeln.
Was richtig next level wäre,
es würde sich jemand einen Monitoring-Server aufsetzen,
der checkt quasi
auf die Benachrichtigungs-E-Mail, ob Twitch live
geht und dann geht was an. Das wäre...
Reiner.
Massive.
Was ich finde,
man kriegt bei
Kickstarter nicht immer die gleichen
Sachen.
Okay.
Das ist schon...
Hm. Na gut.
Hallo Jan...
Jan... Jan Re?
War das richtig?
Oh, jetzt kommen sie alle hier.
WTF. Jetzt sind sie alle am Start.
Auf einen Schlag hat Twitch die
Benachrichtigung rausgeschickt.
Sortiert nach Zufall, nach
Beliebtheit.
Nach Zufall.
Aber der Fingerbot, der ist
immer noch am Start, äh.
Ich meine, warum heißt das Fingerbot?
Das klingt irgendwie anstößig, oder? Findet ihr nicht auch?
Der Fingerbot.
Ach, Discord hat die Benachrichtigung
gesendet. Ach so.
Na dann.
Ja, Homel. So muss das sein.
Übrigens, heute habe ich mit dem Felix
zusammen auf der Arbeit
was aufgenommen. Wie ich
es auf Twitter
ja auch schon gesagt habe.
Ich weiß, ich habe sogar neues Videomaterial.
Ich habe ja vor einer Weile gepostet, dass
wenn wir unsere neuen Server auf der Arbeit kriegen,
warum besteht meine Fotos- und Videosammlung
eigentlich nur aus irgendwelchen sinnlosen
Twitch-Memes und Emotes?
Warum habe ich denn
vor Gitte gepostet?
Drip Twitter.
Ach ja, übrigens.
Hier drauf möchte ich nochmal kurz eingehen.
Ihr wisst was, was ist, ne?
Oh, the fuck.
Geht das automatisch weiter?
Also, guckt mal.
Rot, PC.
Blau,
Playstation.
Grün, Xbox.
Und wisst ihr, was das da oben ist?
Also, das da, das, äh.
Moment, wie
wie kommt man
zu dem Bild?
Leute,
wie, wie, wie, wie, wie kommt man zu dem Bild?
Wie, ja.
Open Image.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das da oben ist?
Das hier.
Wisst ihr, dieser, dieser
äh, lila Anteil
ist richtig.
Das ist Google Stadia.
Wobei ja
Destiny eines der
Launch-Titel gewesen ist.
Ich meine, es gab ja nicht viele Launch-Titel.
Und es, das Spiel hat
insgesamt
äh,
ähm, ich hab übrigens das Mikrofon ein bisschen weit weg, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ähm, Stadia, äh, Schwachsinn.
Das Spiel hat insgesamt
so ungefähr 1,1
Millionen Spieler.
Und auf Stadia spielen
7.000.
7.000 zu 1,1
Millionen.
Also, so viel
Negative Latency können sie gar nicht haben.
So sonderlich zufällig ist das
aber doch nicht, oder? Nach dem
Zufallsprinzip. Ich wähle hier immer wieder
Zufallsprinzip aus und es passiert nichts.
Das ist, also das Zufallsprinzip
ist äußerst zufällig, wie es aussieht.
Huge, huge Zufall.
Ich hatte es nämlich vorhin schon mal kurz auf,
deswegen habe ich mich auch dafür entschieden, dass wir heute
mal Gadgets und Technology machen.
Weil, ähm,
das ist ein 3D-Druck.
Den kann ich daheim für 2 Cent machen.
Ähm,
da waren ein paar ganz interessante Sachen dabei.
Unter anderem das da, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
what the fuck, Alter.
Und, und Walls
sind war auch dabei. Genau, mehr habe ich.
Eine andere Sache habe ich noch geguckt,
der hier. Genau.
Dann habe ich, nachdem ich
ein bisschen durchgeguckt habe, habe ich gesagt, ey, da sind ja
ein paar ganz interessante Sachen dabei.
Da dachte ich mir so, okay, ähm,
machen wir einfach mal Streben an, bevor ich alleine gucke.
Also, wir fangen jetzt mal an
mit dem Fingerbot.
Der Name bringt mich schon, äh, Richtung
Monkatos, ja.
Also der Fingerbot.
Ähm, ich haue die Musik aus.
Also wir gucken, wir gucken jetzt mal den Fingerbot.
Was, was hat der Fingerbot,
der Fingerbot zu bieten?
Ähm, und zwar
wollten die
18.000 Euro, also
die, die, die haben wahrscheinlich einen Dollar, ja.
18k wollten die haben.
Und sie haben bis jetzt, und das läuft
noch 6 Tage, bis jetzt
100.000.
Was auch immer die
für zusätzliche Tiers haben. Mal gucken.
Jetzt gucken wir, jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Fingerbot
an. Ich glaube nicht, dass es was Unanständiges ist.
Obwohl wir gerade 69,
Streamzuschauer haben.
Ja, meine Finger haben tatsächlich Limitierung, wenn ich
mit den Fingern nicht hinkomme. Das ist wahr.
Oh.
Das ist genial.
Mit dem Unterschied,
das ist genial,
mit dem Unterschied, dass es das schon längst gibt.
Ich habe mir sowas vor,
ich habe sogar, ich habe sogar auf Twitter gepostet.
Ähm.
Ich habe mir genau sowas gekauft
vor,
drei Monaten. Warte mal, ich poste
es euch, was ich mir gekauft habe. Das ist überhaupt nichts Neues.
Das ist ein super Teil.
Das ist ein super Teil,
aber ich habe mir genau sowas gekauft.
Warum muss man da Kickstarter für machen?
Warte mal, warte mal. Your Prime Account.
Your Orders.
Bot. Fuck, nach was kann ich ihn da suchen?
Ist das Open Source wahrscheinlich
nicht. Finger.
Nach was kann ich ihn da suchen bei Amazon?
Roboter.
Switch. Switch kann ich suchen.
Switch.
Hier.
Das habe ich mir vor, das habe ich mir
am 2. Oktober bestellt.
Switch Bot. Hier, schaut mal.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Das habe ich mir bei Amazon
vor, vor, vor, vor, vor
drei Monaten bestellt.
Guckt mal.
Ist fast genau das gleiche.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Exakt, exakt, exakt das gleiche.
Guckt mal.
Genau das gleiche.
Wie viel Druck kann das aufwüben?
Ich habe es jetzt nicht aus, also ich habe es jetzt nicht irgendwo drauf drücken lassen.
Aber,
also,
du kannst damit beispielsweise
nicht am Herd
den Knopf reindrücken lassen.
Also,
wenn man, wenn man, nicht am Herd,
am Backofen. Du kannst damit nicht den
Knopf vom Backofen reindrücken lassen, weil das
ist so ein Druckding, so ein, drückst du drauf und dann
kommt er rausgehüpft.
Das ist doch genau das gleiche.
Ok.
So, jetzt vergleichen wir das mal. Also, ihr habt es
jetzt gesehen. Achso, und übrigens, was es noch,
was es noch Cooles gibt.
Wer jetzt denkt, der, dieser
Switch Bot, den ich mir gekauft habe, der kann
nur, übrigens, es scheint gerade
recht teuer zu sein. Ich habe das irgendwie noch
für 19, für 29 Euro, oder
19, oder was habe ich bezahlt?
Ich sage es euch klar. Was habe ich dafür
bezahlt?
Ich habe zwei Stück bestellt.
25 Euro.
25 Euro habe ich dafür bezahlt.
Ist eigentlich auch relativ teuer für so ein kleines Futzding, aber gut.
Was aber ganz cool ist, der
hat noch so einen Kit dabei.
So einen Kit, dass man quasi nicht nur
Schalter drücken kann, sondern auch Schalter, die
quasi nach außen
gezogen werden müssen, nach außen zieht.
Das ist dann so ein kleines,
hier kann man in diese
Öffnung kann man das Attachen und dann auf die andere
Seite dran kleben. Aber,
das sieht mir nach einem ziemlichen Rip-Off
aus, der Switch Bot,
der Finger Bot vom Switch Bot.
Sogar die App sieht ganz schön
ähnlich aus. Übrigens,
das Schöne am Switch Bot ist,
man kann es mit der App steuern, man muss es aber nicht
mit der App steuern, man kann es auch ordentlich
steuern. Aber gucken wir uns mal an, was die
noch so, was die sonst noch haben. Ich meine,
vergleicht man die Dinger, kein großer Unterschied
bis jetzt.
Aber ist eine geniale
Idee, also das Ding ist wirklich ultra praktisch,
aber,
es ist halt keine neue
Idee.
Der Finger Bot,
der Name macht mich fertig.
Bei einem Lichtschalter,
dafür gibt es diese Schnur, die man
Attachen kann, also sprich,
der zieht dann, anstatt nur zu drücken.
Nein, ist überhaupt nicht gestellt.
Es ist nicht gestellt.
Das ist überhaupt nicht, nein, kann nicht sein.
So wie das geschnitten ist,
ist das bestimmt exakt in dieser
zeitlichen Abfolge passiert.
Guck dir denn an.
So easy.
Das hat Steve Jobs auch immer auf seinen alten
iPhone Präsentationen gesagt.
Erstmal, erstmal schön in der Unterwäsche.
In der Unterwäsche,
da ist auch ein Remote Control.
Warum fühlst du dich zu hart, nachdem du
zu hart geht nicht?
Weil, ihr wisst, ihr wisst, warum es nicht geht, oder?
Man kann niemals zu hart sein.
Eine, eine, eine, eine,
eine Finger Bot Cloud.
Wenn man, ah, das ist ein schönes Thema.
Ähm,
Ionel, Lionel,
die Namen auf Twitch teilweise sind so
Next Level Big Brain Shit,
dass ich gar nicht weiß, ich glaube es war Lionel,
Lionel heißen.
Ähm, ähm, ähm,
was wollte ich denn da sagen?
Warum man sich dann nicht einfach eine Glühbirne holt.
Das kann ich dir zeigen.
Und zwar, oder, was heißt zeigen, das kann ich dir erklären.
Weil, ein, ähm,
Lichtschalter
besser ist, als
eine smarte Lampe.
Denn, du möchtest
ja auch dieses Ding bedienen können, per Lichtschalter.
Und wenn du das per Lichtschalter,
also wenn du eine smarte Lampe hast, und du machst
den Lichtschalter aus, dann ist die smarte Lampe auch,
und du kannst die smarte Lampe, egal wie smart sie ist, nicht einschalten, weil sie hat ja keinen Strom.
Das heißt, entweder wirst du nie im Leben wieder deinen Lichtschalter verwenden können
oder die App für das Smart Light Bulb Ding nicht.
Das heißt, die eigentlich beste Variante ist, wenn man RGB-Beleuchtung haben will,
ist sich eine RGB-Lampe oder sonst was zu kaufen, das ist okay.
Aber die Steuerung, ob Licht an oder aus, nicht mit der Lampe zu machen oder mit dem Lichtschalter,
sondern einfach einen Relay einzubauen, also anstelle des Lichtschalters,
dass der Lichtschalter eben nicht direkt die Lampe schaltet, sondern der Lichtschalter den Relay schaltet,
das Relay schaltet die Lampe.
Das ist High IQ.
Dafür gibt es auch schon Disclosure.
Richtig passende Ding.
Habe ich schon ein paar Mal hier im Stream gezeigt.
Ich sollte von Shelly Geld nehmen.
Die Dinger sind nämlich richtig gut.
Habe ich bei mir auch schon ein paar am Start.
Und zwar, Products, ein Shelly 1.
Die sind nämlich so klein, die sind kleiner als ein Sonoff.
Die sind kleiner als ein Sonoff, die kannst du unter Putz in den Lichtschalter einbauen.
Das schließt du dann an.
Du hast den Lichtschalter, also da ist ein Relay drinnen.
Du schließt quasi den Lichtschalter hier an den Switch an.
Du schließt hier den Strom an, sodass es nicht durchgeht.
Und wenn du den Lichtschalter drückst, dann schaltet das Relay die Lampe.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Und das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen.
Also viel besser, als sich irgendwie so ein Smart Licht zu kaufen.
Wofür die Lichter gut sind, ist halt, wenn man RGB haben will.
Wobei ich da ganz ehrlich sage,
was ich sagen muss, ich habe noch keine richtig gute RGB Lampe für so eine E17, was auch immer, Fassung gefunden.
Was ich viel besser finde, ist, wenn man wirklich schönes Belichtungskonzept oder so umsetzen will,
dann würde ich tatsächlich zu LED-Streifen greifen mit einem Microcontroller dran.
Aber, ja, kann man machen.
Aber ich würde auf jeden Fall das Schalten über sowas empfehlen.
Oder alternativ, wenn man das nicht kann,
dann einen Switch-Bot.
Oder eben hier einen Finger-Bot.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Das ist nicht übel.
Also im Prinzip ist es ja von der Technik her nicht viel Unterschied.
Hier schaltet dein Schalter den Relay.
Hier schaltest du quasi einen Schalter, der deinen Schalter schaltet.
Und ein Relay ist ja auch nur ein Schalter-Schalter.
Ach du Scheiße, was denn Satz.
Ja.
Und man darf sich übrigens nicht verwirren lassen.
Muss ich hier auch sagen.
Ich muss es auch nochmal sagen, weil es ist die unglücklichste Adresse.
Die Adresse ist wirklich absolut low IQ, weil die Adresse hier ist shelly.cloud.
Und wisst ihr, was das Hauptverkaufsargument für dieses Ding hier ist?
Dass es ohne Cloud funktioniert.
Da hat sich, da war einer wirklich sehr big brain time am Start bei Shelly.
Weißt du, ich baue was,
wo das Verkaufsargument schlechthin ist, wir benötigen keine Cloud und unsere offizielle
Firmware kann MQTT, kann Rest-API-Schnittstellen, kann alles, kann alle offene Protokolle, also
sprich, ich verkaufe das hauptsächlich an Leute, die keine Cloud verwenden wollen.
Du kannst sogar auf GitHub, kannst du gucken und dann mache ich eine Domain shelly.cloud.
Das genaue Gegenteil von dem, was ich eigentlich vertreibe.
Sonoff, Sonoff.
Hat beides eine Daseinsberechtigung.
Die Sonoff-Dinger sind günstiger und für Geräte, die, die, also für eine Lampe oder so, ja, sind die Sonoffs besser.
Die Dinger sind, oder was heißt besser?
Ja doch, schon besser geeignet, weil die Sonoffs sind zu.
Die Sonoffs, Sonoff, die Sonoffs sind halt zu, aber die Dinger, die sind halt zu.
Da machst du hier, da schneidest du das Kabel von deiner Lampe durch und schließt es hier an und kannst dann damit Remote schalten.
Unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke.
Das Shelly ist halt klein, das kannst du in die Dose, in die Wand machen.
Das Sonoff ist relativ, relativ groß, also das ist doppelt so groß wie ein Shelly ungefähr so hintereinander.
So ein Shelly hintereinander ist ungefähr so eine Sonoff-Größe.
So.
Und da kannst du halt außenrum liegen lassen.
Den Shelly würde ich nicht außen liegen lassen.
Ortenee brauchst du nicht.
Und zwar, du kannst.
Das, das, das geht.
Ich, ich zeig's dir, was du, was du brauchst dafür noch.
Ähm, ich, warte mal, ich guck mal, ich guck mal in mein Amazon, ich guck in mein Amazon.
Sorry Leute, in mein Amazon.
Amazon.
Wir sind ja, wir sind cool, wir benutzen den Amazon.
Alter, ich hab übelst.
Ich bin nicht am Niesen, ich bin am Husten.
Du brauchst für den Switchboard, ist aber dabei.
Musst du nicht extra kaufen.
Äh.
Moment.
Du brauchst.
Hä?
Irgendwie funktioniert der zweite Link nicht.
Da ist so ein Kabel dabei.
Das, das, damit kannst du Lichtschalter an- und ausschalten.
Ähm.
Switchboard.
Ich zeig dir.
Da gibt's, da gibt's.
Ja, gucken wir uns mal, gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
Wir haben uns das sogar schon mal im Stream angeguckt.
Ich hab's sogar schon mal gezeigt.
Ja, zeig, zeig mal her.
Dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
Dum, dum.
So sind die Teile.
Zeig mir die Teile.
Hier, da, da hat er's gezeigt.
Hier.
Da gibt's noch so ein, so ein Ding.
Das ist so ein, so ein, so ein.
Wie nennt man das?
Keine Glasfaser, sieht ein bisschen so aus wie eine Glasfaser.
Ähm.
Das machst du da dran.
Und dann ist es quasi invertet.
Also sprich, dann kannst du das Ding, dann ist es beim Einfahren schaltet es ein, quasi.
Damit kannst du auch einen Lichtschalter schalten.
Funktioniert, hab ich ausprobiert.
It's AF.
Okay, schauen wir uns mal an, was der Finger-Bot noch weiteres zu bieten hat.
Ob das einfach nur so ein Rip-Off ist, ob, ob das noch irgendwie was, was, ähm, okay, er ist, er, er ist erst mal too hot.
... can bring all your finger-bots online, allowing you to control them from anywhere at any time.
Ja gut, das, äh, das haben die auch.
Das, das hat, der Switch-Bot hat genau das Gleiche.
Der hat auch, der hat auch so einen Hub für Leute, die zu Noob-Style sind und das selbst einzurichten.
Now.
... I might ask, what if the button doesn't fit?
Ah.
... if we have it sold.
The arm of the robot can be replaced.
What the fuck?
Das ist genau das Gleiche.
Das ist genau das Gleiche, nur dass die da irgendwie so einen Saugnapf dran gemacht haben.
... Finger-Bot can be modified to fit many different scenarios.
Let your coffee machine automatically prepare a cup of hot coffee.
What the?
Das ist der ultra krasse Rip-Off, ey.
... Set a timer in the app.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Genau so, genau so funktioniert das mit dem Switch-Bot auch.
Set a timer in the app, then the finger...
Also quasi, genau das kann der Switch-Bot auch, nur, dass der Switch-Bot, finde ich, deutlich stabiler montiert ist als dieser komische Saugnapf hier.
Ich, ich glaube nicht, dass der Saugnapf lange hält.
Nice acting.
We also provide a 3D-printing interface for you to create your unique arms to suit any special situation.
Geil, kann ich mit meinem 3D-Drucker neue Finger-Bot-Arme ausbauen.
... Finger-Bot-Arme ausbauen.
Done.
Adapt Prox is dedicated to the design...
Ey, die sollten mal einen 3D-Drucker erfinden, der so schnell druckt wie das hier.
Guckt euch mal, wäre das nicht geil?
... special situation.
Ja, passt mal auf.
Loop, fertig.
So einen 3D-Drucker bräuchte ich ja.
Done.
Adapt Prox is dedicated to the design and production of user-friendly smart home solutions.
We are a young team of visionaries and dreamers.
We are very proud to introduce our finger-bot here in small...
Der Name...
Ich komm nicht über den Namen hinweg, dass das Ding wirklich Finger-Bot heißt.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich der richtige Switch-Bot-Rip-Off.
Okay, Switch-Bot, Finger-Bot.
Da haben sich auch bestimmt schon Leute drüber aufgeregt.
Ey, guck mal, das ist ein Jahr älter.
Wisst ihr, was das Lustige daran ist?
Dass die Leute hier gebackt haben.
So nach dem...
Oh mein Gott, sowas revolutionäres Neues.
Und die können sich das gleiche Produkt einfach schon kaufen.
Können die dafür nicht in der Anzahl...
...Anzeige bekommen?
Kommt drauf an.
Welches Land?
Wie das ausgelegt ist?
Ob da überhaupt was patentiert ist?
Man muss ja auch mal sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man sich das so wirklich...
Ich meine, das ist ein Roboter-Finger.
Roboter-Knopfdrücker.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so Big Brain ist, dass das...
Weiß ich.
Aber ich meine, die Chinesen können Pornhub-Hoodies verkaufen, ohne dass es jemanden interessiert.
Warum sollen die nicht auch einen Finger-Bot machen?
Warum sollen die nicht auch einen Finger-Bot machen können?
Kannst du bitte nochmal erklären, was das Shelly kann?
Hab auch mal geschaut, ob es was gibt, was man per Schalter selbst und per App steuern könnte.
Wenn der Schalter selbst nicht betätigt ist.
Ist das sowas?
Ja, das ist ein Relay.
Du schaltest...
Das Relay kannst du schalten, entweder über WLAN, mit einer App, mit einem MQTT-Server, mit deiner Heimatomatisierung, mit was auch immer.
Oder aber du kannst das Relay auch mit dem Lichtschalter schalten, das funktioniert.
Du kannst beim Shelly, kannst du, du schließt hier den Lichtschalter an.
Oh fuck, ich hab...
Sorry, ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht mehr genau, wie man das anschließt.
Aber hier kommt der Lichtschalter dran.
Ich glaube...
Warte mal.
Hier.
Genau, so in der Richtung.
Ja, doch, doch, so.
Moment, das ist...
Ja.
Das ist ein bisschen doof.
Aber das ist genau sowas, was du haben willst.
Du kannst es dann remote schalten oder hier, hier, hier ist doch, hier ist doch kein...
Hier ist ein schönes Bild dazu, ja.
Du schließt den Lichtschalter an.
Und du kannst quasi mit dem Lichtschalter schaltest du hier drinnen das Relay für das Licht.
Also sprich, du schaltest nicht mehr mit dem Lichtschalter das Licht, sondern du schaltest mit dem Lichtschalter,
triggerst du das Ding und das Ding schaltet ein Relay für das Licht, um das Licht einzuschalten.
Das heißt, du kannst das Relay auch über WLAN triggern.
Das Ding hat ein, das Ding, das Ding hat ein ESP 32 drinnen mit WLAN, kannst du triggern über MQTT, über, über REST, über HTTP oder auch über die App von denen.
Geht beides, ja.
Und, ähm, dann kannst du mit dem Schalter nach wie vor Licht an- und ausschalten.
Das ist für die Frau, Freundin, Mutter, Opa, Oma ganz gut, weil die wollen Knopfe drücken, ja.
Knopf, muss, Knopf drücken am Eingang, da muss Licht angehen.
Und es ist halt auch relativ schnell.
Alle anderen Lösungen sind, sind nicht so schön.
Es gibt ja quasi auch, ähm, WLAN-Schalter, ja, also WLAN, WLAN-Schalter gibt's ja im Prinzip auch, die kannst du hinmachen, aber das dauert.
Da muss der Schalter erstmal zur Heimautomatisierung, die Heimautomatisierung muss das Licht schalten und so.
Das ist nicht so, ähm, ein Sonoff Mini bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob der so gut in die Dose passt.
Der Sonoff Mini kam, glaube ich, auch später.
Nach dem Shelly.
Der Sonoff Mini sieht einen Ticken größer aus.
Das Schöne ist halt die Form.
Es ist eng, es ist relativ eng in der, in der, in der Dose.
Aber es passt rein, guckt's euch mal an.
Jetzt, guck, jetzt zeigt das.
Das ist die Dose, da muss das rein.
Also, es ist, es ist eng, aber es geht.
Und Leute, macht vorher die Sicherung raus.
Ich sag's jetzt nur, ich meine, es sollte eigentlich selbstverständlich sein, dass man da nicht irgendwie...
...an Live-Kabeln und so, äh, rumbastelt.
Aber macht die Sicherung raus.
Ich sag's nur, nicht, dass irgendeiner nachher ankommt so nach dem Motto, äh, Max, ich bin im Krankenhaus, weil, ne, ich wollte mal ein Shelly einbauen.
Ja, macht die Sicherung raus.
So, mal gucken, ob man's am Ende, ob man's am Ende sieht.
Übrigens, ihr könnt das auch euren Elektriker machen lassen, ist auch kein Problem.
Ähm, ich hab das, ich hab das auch mit meinem Elektriker gemacht, weil ich trau...
Ich trau mich an...
...alles machen.
Alles mögliche ranzufrickeln, bloß bei allem ab 100 Volt plus hab ich so ein bisschen Schiss.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ähm, aber jetzt weiß ich, wie's funktioniert und das ist ziemlich easy.
Strom, MonkaS, ja.
Ähm, ich, mal gucken, ob man's am Ende zeigt.
Ihr könnt das auch euren Elektriker machen lassen.
Wenn ihr dem sagt, ihr wollt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10 Steckdosen umrüsten, dann kostet's 100 Euro.
So.
Ich hoffe mal, er zeigt's am Ende, weil das ist ganz schön...
Moment, hat er sich davor gedrückt?
Zeig noch mal, wie's drinne ist.
Zeig, weil das ist ganz schön eng.
Ah.
Und jetzt sind Shelly rei...
Nein, äh, ja.
Zeig mal, wie's fertig aussieht.
Ah, es ist nämlich, da ist nicht viel Platz drinne.
Je nachdem, wie viel Kabel man drin hat und klemmen.
Ah, genau.
Also da, also ihr seht, da ist nicht viel Platz.
Und passt, ne?
Und dann...
...zumachen gut ist.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Das Ding.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich toll.
Und es ist auch nicht teuer.
Ähm, die haben manchmal...
Guck mal.
9,90 Euro.
Das ist, das ist...
Der Preis ist fast schon, fast schon in Regionen von nem normalen Sonoff.
9,90.
Kannst dich nicht beschweren.
Es ist aus...
Kommt aus Bulgarien.
Und der Versand ist auch nicht so teuer.
Die haben, die haben noch jede Menge mehr.
Die haben noch jede Menge mehr.
Die haben beispielsweise auch noch mit Power-Measurement.
Also sprich, da kann man dann auch gucken, was die, was die angeschlossenen Geräte für
den Strom verbrauchen.
So.
Kaufen wir mal nen Shelly 1 und gucken mal, was es kosten würde nach Deutschland.
Ähm...
4,80.
Also, das ist preis-leistungsmäßig wirklich in Ordnung.
Also, wenn ihr euch jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich hab, ich hab mal irgendwann so
nen 20er-Pack Shellys bestellt.
Äh.
Ich hab die Seite gebackt.
Grip.
Leute, ich hab die Seite kaputt gemacht.
Ich refresh mal.
20er-Pack Shellys.
Zack.
Wir sehen im Arsch die Seite.
So.
Dann legst du noch 17 Euro Versand drauf.
Muss mal gucken, ab wann das, ab wann das hochgeht.
Ähm...
Bäm.
Du kannst das ganze Haus mit ausrüsten.
Ich hab übrigens...
Die meisten liegen noch neben mir hier, ne?
In der Kiste.
Ähm...
Das ist wirklich super, super Preis.
Ja, also...
Und ich kann's, ich kann's...
Ich kann's...
Und ich kannst, ich kann's insofern auch nur empfehlen, den Hersteller zu unterstützen,
weil das ist einer der wenigen, die von Anfang an die ganze Sache offen gemacht habe, sprich
du kannst den- glaube den Sourcecode anschauen auf GitHub und die Firmware, die standard-mäßig
drauf ist.
Du kannst TAS Motor Flashen, aber du musst TAS Motor nicht flashen.
Du kannst die offizielle Firmware drauf lassen, weil die offizielle Firmware auch alle Schnittstellen
beherrscht die man braucht.
Und es gibt sogar noch eine App, ähm, irgenwo.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ähm...
Wenn man, wenn man das nicht in seiner Eigenheit kennt.
heimat automatisierungslösung integrieren wollen wenn man die einfach einbauen will
app verwenden will und gut das ding ist wirklich gut das kann ich kann ich empfehlen also 200 euro
mit einem elektriker ja das ist das ist billig das ist richtig billig größte mal woanders dann
hat das mit der bezahlst du dich ja dumm und dämlich so viel bezahlte für drei smart klüger
kann man mit ssh darauf zugreifen kann man nicht das sind sp 32 ich habe keine ahnung
für den sp2 reichen ssh sauber gibt vor allem wird es dafür keine shell geben und was soll die
schellern machen du hast ein web interface du hast ein web interface du hast ein web interface und
du hast alle möglichen api schnittstellen die du brauchst ja leider macht das ist das ist das ist
wirklich preis leistungsmäßig ist das ding wirklich top und von den funktionen her ist es auch top und
konnte kannst ja mal ein bisschen auf der seite umgucken die haben die haben auch viel mehr coole
sachen
sehe das ganze was sehe das ganze smartphone aus sicherheitsaspekten eher kritisch wie stehst du
dazu sehe ich auch so deswegen mache ich auch selbst ich würde mir nie im leben auf die idee
kommen da einen alexa oder einen google home anzuschließen sofern der auf alles zugreifen
dürfte also ich würde nie ein fertiges apple smart home apple google amazon smart home oder
sowas verwenden was ich mache ist ich mache das selbst mit home assistant deswegen flashe ich
ja auch alles deswegen lege ich ja auch so viel wert darauf dass die geräte
die ich mir kaufe über so standardisierte schnittstellen ansprechbar sind deswegen
ist mir das ja auch so wichtig und sollte ich mir mal einen alexa hinstellen übrigens
wahrscheinlich werde ich demnächst mal weil wahrscheinlich werde ich demnächst mal das
ausprobieren damit kann man sich mit dem raspberry pi den voice assistant selbst bauen allerdings der
kann natürlich standardmäßig nicht so viel und wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht so advanced sein wie
alexa oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google
alexa oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google oder google cir Iowa
für fünf sechs sätze die man öfters brauchen die nervig sind man gucken mal gucken wie das
funktioniert wenn ich in nächster zeit mal ausprobieren heimat automatisierung ist so
ein ding wenn man einmal damit angefangen hat kann man kann man nicht mal aufhören
das show me ein kameralie ja nicht nur das nicht nur dass das
ja pass mal auf ich weiß gar nicht ob mir das schon ob ihr das mitbekommen habt die hatten da hat hier mal ein anhand des teils ähnlicher oder einer eure info und die voran Move. tributs manually Чтоằng
in seiner heimat automatisierung auf einmal die wohnung von anderen leuten gesehen guckt euch das
mal der macht sein google der macht sein google home auf der macht sein google home auf drückt
drückt hier drückt ja auch kameras und auf einmal kriegt dann ein bild angezeigt von der fremden
wohnung fremde wohnung kriegt da angezeigt also das ist schon das ist schon richtig fällt deswegen
stehe ich der sache auch kritisch gegenüber und ich mache es selbst wenn ich wenn ich selbst mache
dann verkacke ich wenigstens auch selbst aber nachdem man wenn man das selbst macht relativ
genau weiß was man macht bestehen solche chancen gar nicht weil das da solche sachen oder auch
hier dass das weiß cam liegt das ist ja auch so ein ding gewesen ja ihr personal data auf 2,4
millionen security cameras konnte stream abgreifen dass das
da das passiert ja nur einzig und allein weil es ins internet geschickt wird zu irgendeinem anbieter
was komplett hirnrissig ist weil man sich mal genau überlegt wenn ich mein smart home also quasi ich
möchte mein zuhause angenehmer für mich gestalten und warum sollte ich mich quasi dann darauf
verlassen dass irgendwelche leute in der cloud ich muss quasi ich muss quasi die daten aus meinem
haus rausschicken damit ich mein haus wieder starten kann und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen
wie ich meine gemeinheit nicht zu verstehen ist weil ich nicht gar gut versteuern kann das ist einfach
das ist einfach irrsinnig und irgendwie absolut deswegen verstehe ich auch die ganzen cloud
lösungen nicht und man darf auch nicht vergessen man ist auf gedeih und verderben von den herstellern
abhängig lässt die monats von google gekauft haben thermostate gemacht wie konntest du bis dahin
relativ gut integrieren und mitten letzten jahres haben sie gesagt also seitdem sie von google gekauft
Oh ne, unsere API machen wir dicht.
Und jetzt sitzen ganz viele Leute da, die haben ein Nest-Thermostat zu Hause
und können es mit ihrer Heimautomatisierung nicht mehr anstreuern.
Das sei denn, sie stellen alles, was sie haben, um auf Google Home.
Was natürlich Google geil findet.
Und nachdem sich kein Anbieter irgendwie mit Ruhm bekleckert hat,
so nach dem Motto, wir schneiden Voice Assistant-Geschichten mit,
wir spielen Voice Assistant-Sachen vor,
natürlich nur, um die Qualität zu verbessern und solche Sachen.
Man kann der ganzen Sache total einfach aus dem Weg gehen,
indem man es einfach selber macht, wenn man es machen kann.
Es ist manchmal anstrengender, ganz klar,
aber du weißt halt auch genau, was ist.
Also, ja.
Da wäre ich, also generell, bei fertigen Smart-Hub-Geschichten,
bei fertigen Home-Automatisierungen, so wie Apple Home,
wie heißt das, HomeKit?
Und Google Home, und was es da nicht alles gibt.
Im Leben würde ich mir das nicht daheim hinstellen.
Man kann eine Alexa-Integration machen, ja, das geht.
Aber dann hat Alexa auch nur Zugriff auf das, was ich haben will,
wenn man halt Alexa haben möchte, ja.
Ähm, nee, nee.
Das kommt bei mir nicht hin.
Also, bei mir kommt nur was hin, was ich selbst einrichten kann.
So.
Wir wollen übrigens mal weiter, weiter Kickstarter gucken.
Was hältst du von Snips für Smart-Hub?
Easy-Killer, schön, dass du fragst.
Snips, genau, nächstes Negativ-Beispiel.
Snips war ein richtig guter Voice-Assistent-Alternative
für Leute, die gerne Do-It-Yourself basteln.
Snips wurde jetzt gekauft von, ähm,
äh, nicht Sonoff, äh, wie heißt es, Sonos?
Sonos?
So, die wurden jetzt gekauft und Snips wird dicht gemacht.
Das heißt,
was man daran auch sieht,
man darf sich für die Steuerung von seinem, von seinem
Home nicht auf Cloud-Dienste verlassen.
Ich kann mich noch an den Thread auf Reddit erinnern,
wo jemand rum, aus Kanada,
wo jemand aus Kanada rumgeflamed hat,
ähm, dass er seine Heizung nicht anmacht,
ich meine, in Kanada ist kalt, ja,
seine Heizung nicht anmachen kann,
weil, äh, sein Internet ausgefallen ist
und das Nest-Thermostat keine Verbindung zur Nest-Cloud hat.
Tja, schon kacke, wenn den anmachen kann.
Wenn man den Arsch abfrieren muss, weil dein Thermostat nicht ins Internet kommt.
Und sowas, sowas ist halt einfach nur idiotisch,
sowas sich überhaupt ins Haus zu holen.
War bestimmt eine Excusy, ja.
Der hat dann gesagt, go again!
Nein, die neue Home Assistant-Vollstuhl habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Die braucht aber auch teilweise Home Assistant-Cloud und sonst was
und sie kann auch kein Deutsch
und das kann ich meiner Mutter auf keinen Fall aufs Auge nehmen,
weil meine Home Assistant, der nicht Deutsch sprechen kann, ne.
Ähm, und es funktioniert auch noch nicht über die iOS-App,
also, äh, die kann ich nicht aufs Auge nehmen.
Also, äh, die kann ich nicht aufs Auge nehmen,
alles Sachen, die für mich das nicht so attraktiv machen.
Ich werde das mal mit Respy ausprobieren, als nächstes.
So, okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Was, was gibt's hier noch Schönes, Schönes?
Ähm, den Finger-Bot hatten wir jetzt.
Ähm, was halt Rip-Off ist von, von, ähm, von dem, was ich euch gezeigt hab, von Smartbot.
Oh, was haben die für Stretch-Goals?
Okay, Integrate Finger-Bot mit Stretch-Goals, 100k!
What the fuck?
Fuck, Alter, guck mal, die haben normal, die wollten normal 18k,
und dann macht man als Stretch-Goal, macht man nicht bei 25k,
sondern irgendwie gleich mal bei 100k, ne.
Ähm, Smart-Things-Integration.
Smart-Things ist genau so ein Ding, das würde ich auch im Leben nicht verwenden.
Ähm, Finger-Bot-Caller, Wireless-Charging-Message, ZigBee-Wi-Fi-Version.
Das hier, das Ding sollte über irgendeine Form von offenen Standards,
offenen Schnittstellen steuerbar sein.
Ansonsten ist das Crap.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Was, Mi, Mi-Dry.
Ein Föhn.
Das ist ein Föhn.
Einfach ein Föhn.
Okay, ein Föhn.
Hast du sicherheitstechnisch Probleme mit IFTTT?
Ich verwende IFTTT nicht.
Ähm, okay, ein Föhn.
Super Speed, Ultimate Compactness.
Also, der Griff ist schon mal doppelt so lang,
zumindest sieht das auf dem Bild so aus wie von meinem billigen, kleinen Föhn.
High IQ.
Ja, ja, schick, schick, schick's mir im Discord, Michael.
Schick's mir im Discord.
Und, und spamm ich da ein bisschen voll, also erst, wenn ich gesagt habe, ich hab's gesehen, aufhören.
Weil, sonst übersehe ich das.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was das Ding hier ist.
Hat der Alexa-Integration?
Werden wir gleich, werden wir gleich feststellen.
Boah.
Hottes Grill beim Haareföhnen.
What the fuck?
Drei...
Muss das sein?
Warum immer diese NA-Units?
Was ist denn 30 MPH?
MPS?
Pro Sekunde.
Äh, okay, es ist 50 kmh.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was so normaler Föhn,
Föhn, kmh,
außerdem ist das wahrscheinlich ziemlich egal.
Luftgeschwindigkeit von 208.
Luftgeschwindigkeit 120 kmh.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so entscheidend ist.
Ähm, solange es genug ist.
Ups, ähm, wo ist er?
Aerodynamische Struktur.
Ich glaub, viel aerodynamischer.
Ich glaub, also, ich mein, so normaler Föhn,
Da kann doch gar nicht viel aerodynamischer sein.
Ich mein, ähm, das geht hinten rein und bläst vorne raus.
Was soll da nicht aerodynamischer sein?
Ich mein, da kann vielleicht mehr Luft ansaugen,
Je nachdem, wie viel, wie viel Luftansauge-Dinger hier das hat.
Aber dass der andere Föhn ist halt hinten komplett aus.
Ist wieder Dyson, das ist Scam.
Aha, hab ich aber noch nie, noch nie gehört.
Guck mal, als wäre das ein Vorteil, dass es einen Knopf hat.
Am besten, ich bin ja jemand,
Ich bin der Meinung, direktes Feedback,
Wenn man Knöpfe drückt, ist wichtig.
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich den Knopf in verschiedene
Klickmuster mir merken, dass ich weiß,
was niedrig, mittel und hoch ist.
Am besten wäre,
ähm, einfach einen Knopf mit drei Stufen.
Aus, mittel, an, fertig.
Redefine Hairdryer.
Alter, jetzt übertreibt das aber.
Jetzt übertreibt das aber.
Redefine Hairdryer.
Ähm...
Ja, gut.
Brauch ich nicht.
Oh, die hat aber eklige Sachen in den Haaren.
Ey.
Wenn sowas aus dem Füll rauskommt...
Wo saugt das Ding überhaupt Luft an, richtig?
Wenn es das nicht hinten ansaugt, sondern unten?
Gut, was auch immer, juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Das ist Scam.
Warum ist das Scam?
Wartet mal.
Ja, gut, das sieht tatsächlich relativ ähnlich aus.
Aber, es kostet 360 Euro.
Das andere kostet angeblich nur 50 Euro.
Ähm...
Und das kann ja das andere gar kein so großer Scam sein,
wenn es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Ähm...
Was Scam ist, ist...
Genau, was einer Freund geschrieben hat.
Die Wasserflasche, die sich selbst auffüllt.
Oder der Regen.
Wie hieß dieses Regending nochmal?
Der Waterseer.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Der Waterseer?
Das war auch Scam.
Das war ein Huge Scam, der Waterseer.
Okay, guck mal, was hab ich?
Wallsun.
Fingerabdruck?
Ein Fingerabdruck-Fahrradschloss?
Oh.
Guck mal, der hat ein bisschen Video-Synchronisierungsprobleme.
Guck mal, Mundbewegung an.
Es wirkt so wie so eine schlecht
nachsynchronisierte Sitcom von früher.
Guckt euch die Mundbewegung an
und dann, was er sagt.
Hahaha.
Really annoying situations
like this.
Haha!
Sowas seh ich in Frankfurt täglich.
Maybe like this.
You know that
Bill, and so do we.
Wallsun comes in.
Wallsun is a compact disc
break fingerprint Micron.
Only 220 grams in weight,
it's so easy to carry.
Wallsun locks on to the disc break,
providing durable protection.
Es sieht nicht so stabil aus, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Und was genau hindert jetzt jemand daran, das Fahrrad zu klauen?
Hm, aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich glaube nicht, dass man das sehr stabil bauen kann, weil ich meine, es muss beweglich sein, es muss so beweglich sein, dass es irgendwie automatisch entlocken kann, also da ist irgendeine Elektronik drin, für das Schloss, also sprich, ich muss ja Fingerabdruck machen und dann muss es irgendwie aufgehen, nachdem ich den fähre, muss irgendeine Elektronik drin sein, also an der Stelle kann das schon mal gar nicht so super stabil sein.
Und, ähm, das sah jetzt auch nicht so stabil aus.
Und eventuell kann man es sogar ganz easy knacken, ja, genau.
Ähm, das kann ich, kann ich, kann ich nichts zu sagen, kann ich mich nicht aus, aber das sieht nicht so aus, als ist es so, so wahnsinnig stabil.
Ah, gut.
Zum Thema Fingerprint-Schloss.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Das ist aber kein Schloss.
Haha, Schloss, reimt sich auf Monkartos.
Passt mal, Leute, guckt mal, Big Brain, Big Brain, äh, Twitch, ähm, Chrome-Erweiterung, die ich hier installiert habe, guckt mal.
End-Answer.
This lock is fast, very fast.
In fact, it's probably the fastest and easiest gun lock that I have ever tested.
Nearly as fast as nothing at all.
Let me show you how it works.
You simply hold the gun as you would normally hold it, and your finger naturally falls right above the fingerprint sensor.
If you slide your finger down and press on the sensor, this clamshell pops open and the lock falls away.
Na gut, müssen wir uns mal so angucken.
That fast we got in.
Das sieht aber gut aus.
Das sieht aber auch nicht stabil aus.
So, you can see it's very quick to access the gun, and in practical terms...
Das ist, das ist so eine richtige, das ist so eine richtig typische Kokona-Sache wieder.
Erst eine Pistole kaufen, dann mit der Pistole rumlaufen, aber dann ist es ja doof, wenn man mit der Pistole rumläuft, dass dann auch theoretisch jeder an die Pistole dran kann, und dann macht man ein Schloss an die Pistole.
Das ist, das ist typisch Kokona-Logik.
That means we can forgive some shortcomings.
Man könnte ja auch alternativ keine Pistole tragen.
Da kann auch keiner an die Pistole mitnehmen, da kann auch keiner an die Pistole...
Aber gut, das ist...
Das ist das, was du besser mit Cree-Style aus der Hüfte schießen kannst, ohne Lock.
Oh, bam, bam, bam!
Wie kriegst du denn das vor allem in den Holster da rein?
Achso, da wird sich ein Waffenschrank einfach anbieten daheim.
Oder ist das eher, weil man das auf dem Nachttisch...
Auf dem Nachttisch liegen haben möchte und so, dass die Kinder nicht dran können, wenn es auf dem Nachttisch liegt.
Weil man braucht ja natürlich logischerweise die Pistole auf dem Nachttisch.
Okay, klingt sogar ganz sinnvoll.
Wenn du schwitzt, ist schlecht.
Oh, scheiße, ich werde überfallen.
Ich bin ziemlich, ziemlich aufgeregt und am Schwitzen.
Scheiße, meine Pistole geht nicht auf.
Warte einen Moment, erst mal...
Durchatmen, beruhigen, fingertrocken putzen und dann kannst du die Einbrecher erschießen.
So, you don't need to search for the backup keys.
If for some reason...
You can't use your fingerprint.
Third, this is made out of what seems to be glass reinforced nylon,
which is a very strong material, at least as far as plastics go.
However, its rigidity is not great.
That means when you twist it a little bit...
Ganz schön wackelig, ja.
You can see, it's not too hard to access that trigger.
So you can imagine a child prying on this with something thin...
Vor allem kannst du das wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut, wenn du einen Schraubenzieher oder noch besser Gordon Freeman-Styles und Brecheisen...
...oder so.
...might be able to push that trigger and discharge.
Man könnte auch einfach, wie es der Rick sagt, einfach den Schlüssel im Schloss drinne lassen.
Next level security.
...firearm.
Personally, I'd be willing to pay more if this was made out of something more rigid.
Perhaps a billet aluminum.
Finally, we have the keyed backup.
To access it, you actually have to pop this cover off.
And if I were actually using this, I would leave this cover off all the time.
Because it's not particularly easy to get off.
The company suggests using the tip of the key, but I haven't had a lot of luck with that.
You can see, you insert the key, and of course it works perfectly.
This appears to be an 8-pin dimple lock with 4 pins on each side opposing each other.
It looks intimidating, but is it enough to stop a curious adolescent?
Which is my litmus test for most trigger locks.
Another way to put that is...
...can I open this?
You can open it with a low-skill attack.
Now, a lot of these cheaper Chinese dimple locks can be opened quickly with low-skill raking attacks.
So that's what we're going to try.
Wow, jetzt kommt next level big brain shit.
And here is a ridged piece of metal.
We're going to use this as a dimple rake.
What?
Alter, was ist jetzt los?
Okay, you can see...
What?
That was pretty darn fast.
The question remains...
Warum funktioniert das?
Plus eins Lockpicking, ja.
Er hat 20 gewürfelt.
Okay, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das so einfach ist.
If you'd like to see more like it, please subscribe.
And as always, have a nice day.
Thank you.
Okay, das wird wahrscheinlich mit dem Fahrradschloss ähnlich sein.
Weil das Fahrradschloss hat garantiert auch noch ein Schloss.
Weil es könnte ja mal sein, dass der Fingerabdrückssensor kaputt ist, dann kriegst du dein Fahrrad nicht mehr auf.
Max, du glaubst gar nicht, wie viele Schlösser da schon geklackt haben.
Naja, doch, glaube ich.
Glaube ich, weil der Channel heißt Lockpicking-Lawyer.
Ja.
Mit 1,2 Millionen Subs.
Der hat garantiert schon viele Schlösser geklackt.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Joy Duo.
Ultra Portable USB-C Hub.
Und Stand...
Oh, MacBook.
Geht sowas bei Mac Leuten schon als Dockingstation durch?
Das wäre bei mich...
Äh, bei mich, Alter.
Das wäre bei mir so ein Viertel Dockingstation.
Das Ding.
Ein Viertel von der Dockingstation ist das ungefähr.
Hi, I just got the MacBook Pro.
But all the hard drives...
With Joy Duo...
With all the hubs in the market...
With Joy Duo, it's all different.
Ah, yes, Apple-User.
Joy Duo is...
The Joy Duo...
Was haben wir, was haben wir?
Moment mal, ich gucke.
Äh, Klinkeanschluss.
HDMI.
Sorry, Leute, Leute, wir sind echt...
USB-C.
Ähm.
Moment, ist das überhaupt USB...
Äh, ist das überhaupt HDMI?
Ja, das ist...
Das ist ein Display-Port.
So, und das an der Seite ist...
Ups, nochmal USB-C.
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Ah, Thunderbolt.
Thunderbolt.
Also, ja, USB-C.
Guck mal!
Das ist...
Das ist ein Fünftel von einer ordentlichen Dockingstation.
USB-C, das ist Thunderbolt.
An der Seite.
Aha.
Ach, deswegen auf beiden Seiten.
Wow!
Huge, huge acting, Leute.
Huge acting.
Guckt euch mal an.
Wow!
Zwei Stück.
Ähm, ich muss sagen, keine schlechte Sache.
Finde ich gut, unter der Voraussetzung,
dass die anderen, ähm,
ähm, Hubs wirklich so kacke sind, wie er sagt.
Ich kenne mich mit MacBook, ähm, MacBook-Docking-Stations
und sowas überhaupt nicht aus.
Die zwei Thunderbolt-Ports an der Seite
sind fähig, dein MacBook Pro mit 100 Watt Power zu schalten.
Sie können auch für schnelle Datentransfer und Video-Outputs genutzt werden.
Was? 100 Watt?
Was ist, was ist denn das?
Was, was ist denn das? 12 Volt?
12 Volt mit, mit...
5?
Nee.
100?
Was ist denn das?
24 Volt mit, mit...
5 Amp...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was da, für was da drüber geht.
32?
32 ist aber ganz schön schäpp.
The Joy Duo also includes a Gigabit Ethernet Port
and a 3.5mm Audio Port.
The Joy Duo has three USB 3.0 Ports
that can transfer data in seconds.
Jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen über Apple lästern, ne?
Ähm, wenn man halt auch ein Notebook baut, was keine USB-Anschlüsse hat,
dann braucht man sowas halt dabei.
Wenn man das Notebook dünner baut, um auf die letzten paar USB-Anschlüsse zu verzichten,
müssen die Leute halt künstliche Notebook dicker machen,
um wieder an die USB-Anschlüsse zu bekommen.
1 Volt und 100 Ampere.
Und wie lang ist das Kabel?
Wie lang darf das Kabel maximal sein?
Zwei Zentimeter?
Also be used to connect the keyboard and mouse.
Und das помine ich gut.
Este
Es sieht ziemlich hakelig aus, damitque drum zu hantieren.
Ich muss lieber so lang und setzigOL sodaverSenn.
Randocken, rechts randocken.
Wie wäre es mit einer ganz normalen Dockingstation?
Aber ich finde es sinnvoll.
Also alles, was wir bis heute gesehen haben,
das ist das Sinnvollste bisher.
Das hört sich an...
Das Work hat sich angehört
wie ein Warcraft 3 Worker, oder?
Work, work.
Hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Work, wherever you need it.
Bisschen, bisschen.
And take it wherever you need it.
Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Das ist...
Oh, Alter.
Die Apple-Leute.
Den kannst du alles verkaufen.
Ja?
Also...
Wir müssten ein Kickstarter-Projekt machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Steve Jobs' linker Socken
wurde jetzt gefunden.
Und wir haben ihn quasi mit einem 3D-Drucker
50 Minuten lang
mal ausgedruckt.
Und wir verkaufen jetzt Steve Jobs' linken Socken.
Und dann machen wir einen Apple-Kickstarter
und das geht ab wie sonst was.
Ich finde es ein bisschen umständlich,
dass du da mit zwei Sachen rumhantieren musst, mobil.
Zumal, guckt mal.
Mobil brauchst du in der Regel kaum Anschlüsse.
Willst du es als Desktop-Ersatz verwenden,
dann könnte man sich noch einfach
eine ganz normale
Docking-Station hinstellen.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Docking-Station
nicht so einfach.
Gibt es überhaupt MacBook-Docking?
Gibt es sowas?
Ja.
Warum nicht einfach sowas?
Naja, keine Ahnung.
Aber das macht einen ganz sinnvollen Eindruck.
Up to 40 GB Data.
Gut, äh, theoretisch.
In der Theorie, ja.
In der Theorie.
5K, 60 FPS.
Okay, ist bestimmt ganz sinnvoll.
Ja, muss ich zugeben.
Ich will es jetzt nicht zu schlecht reden.
Ähm,
kann durchaus,
muss was sinnvolles sein, ja.
Ich meine, ist jetzt nichts irgendwie super herausragendes oder so,
aber warum nicht?
Wirklich, wirklich günstiger als die anderen Docking-Station
ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Ähm,
Januar Mass Production.
Aha, aha, aha.
Schauen wir mal,
was so die Kommentare sagen,
ob das denn überhaupt im Zeitplan liegt.
Es gab noch keine Updates.
Noch keine Updates.
Seit einem Monat, und im Januar soll die Mass-Production anfangen.
Und die ersten Leute sind schon am flamen, dass sie irgendwas nicht sehen.
40 GB File Transfer.
Das will ich sehen.
Wie macht der 40 GB File Transfer?
Wo gibt's das?
Ähm,
das will ich sehen.
Wo, wo stand's hier?
Wo gibt's das Video?
Test Video Part, okay, okay.
Test Video.
Ah, hier.
File Transfer Speeds.
40, 40 Gigabit.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, mir fällt ja nämlich nix ein, mit was man das machen soll.
Aber, schauen wir mal.
Oh, das ist ja mal ein Huge Brain Benchmark Programm.
What?
Was seh ich da überhaupt?
Kann man das nicht noch ein bisschen mehr pic-,
noch ein bisschen pixeliger machen bitte?
Weißt du?
Wenn wir ein MacBook Pro haben und sonst was,
aber keine gescheite Kamera.
Das,
das zeigt mir aber keine 40 Gigabit, das zeigt mir 430 Mbit.
Okay, das ist absolut nichtssagend.
Okay, weiter im Text.
Für ein Screen Capture Programm war kein Geld mehr da.
Ja, das ist schon teuer, wenn man,
wenn man so eine tolle Docking Station bauen muss.
So, was haben wir hier?
8-Bit Warps,
8-Bit We-
Okay, irgendein Musikding.
Definitiv nix für mich, aber man weiß ja nie.
Vielleicht ist ja für euch was dabei.
Wow.
Monkeys.
Jetzt hier.
DJ Grill.
Grausame Musik.
Geht das überhaupt als Musik durch?
Ähm, okay.
Ja.
Gut, wer das für,
man weiß ja nie, für wen das ist.
Also, vielleicht ist das viel geiler, als es für mich aussieht,
als, äh,
unwissender, was Musik angeht.
Die geht da richtig ab,
hier an dem Teil.
Damit, ja, okay.
Was hältst du von Oszilloskop-Musik?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
8-Bit Warps.
Warps, nicht Raps.
Sonic Wear.
Japan.
Also, ein
Ayaya-Produkt.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, wofür man es braucht.
Aber, heißt nicht,
dass es schlecht sein muss.
So, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Flash Forest.
Was?
Using drones to plant one billion
mit Drohnen?
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht.
Okay.
Huge success, hier.
Every year the planet loses 13 billion trees
and regains less than half of that.
We started Flash Forest with the goal
of healing the planet's lungs
and taking that job seriously.
Until that job is done well, no other job really matters.
Timber companies are improving their technology
year over year.
They are lean, they are efficient,
they use advanced all-terrain vehicles,
artificial intelligence
and even autonomous logging trucks.
Artificial intelligence?
Ich konnte dem Satz nicht folgen.
Really good at cutting down trees,
but how are we at planting them?
Well, by and large,
the technology is essentially this.
Our company Flash Forest uses drones,
aerial mapping technology,
automation and ecological science
to plant trees at a rate that until now
hasn't been possible.
Ein AI-Trieb?
One of our pilots can control
ten of these drones.
That's the pace we're gonna need
to fight climate change.
Check out these pods.
Ich glaube,
allein mit Bäume pflanzen
ist es nicht getan.
Es ist keine schlechte Sache,
aber man müsste vielleicht erst mal
ein bisschen weniger die Umwelt verschmutzen.
Das wäre schon mal ein guter Ansatz.
Inside each one of these
are three pre-germinated tree seeds.
Vielleicht sollten wir auch mal
dafür sorgen, dass man nicht
von einem Satellitenbild
quasi komplett eigene Landmassen
erkennen kann, um dann festzustellen, ach nee,
das ist ja einfach nur ein riesen Kontinent
quasi fast schon an Plastik, der im Meer schwimmt.
Wie pflanzen die denn die Bäume überhaupt?
Das hat man überhaupt nicht gesehen, oder?
Wie haben die das gesagt?
Werfen die da irgendwie Samen ab?
Oder wie pflanzen die Dinger?
Die werfen diese Kugeln ab da.
Die schießen das.
Ach, die schießen das
in die Erde, oder was?
Das ist quasi so eine Softair,
also nee, eher so ein bisschen
größere Softair.
Tactical new incoming.
And enough nutrients to sustain
them for nine months.
And not only that.
Ach, das schießt den Kram in die Erde.
The real yolk.
Twitch Brian, dankeschön.
Species counts.
No longer will reforestation
focus only on a handful of trees.
We choose plants that support
full ecosystem recovery.
Das ist wieder so ein Ding,
was echt cool klingt.
Ich glaube, wenn man da
in Ruhe drüber nachdenkt,
wenn man da in Ruhe drüber
nachdenkt, glaube ich, kommt man
auf jede Menge Schwierigkeiten,
die der Sache im Weg stehen.
Es klingt erstmal cool,
aber ich denke, umso mehr man sich da Gedanken drüber macht,
umso mehr Schwachstellen wird man da
allein schauen, ohne großartig
in die Details zu gehen, drinnen finden.
Aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass das tatsächlich mal ein Projekt ist,
dass die Leute zumindest hier
die man da im Video sieht und die das Projekt durchführen,
dass die das zumindest aus Überzeugung machen,
dass das was Gutes ist.
Den Klimawandel aufhalten wir jetzt garantiert nicht,
wenn da ein paar Drohnen rumfliegen und
Dings in den Boden
schießen.
Warum nicht?
Zum Beispiel, das erste, was mir einfällt,
so eine Drohne zu bauen,
die Batterien, das ganze Zeug,
müsste man sich jetzt mal überlegen,
was man dafür braucht,
ob das die Anzahl an Bäumen,
ich weiß es nicht,
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich finde es ist eine gute Idee.
Ich glaube aber, dass es einige
Probleme hat,
die letztendlich dazu führen werden,
dass es sich nicht so super
rentiert, wie man vielleicht denkt.
Ich meine, die wollen 150.000
Bäume pflanzen,
das könntest du einfacher haben, oder?
150.000 Bäume pflanzen, einfach mal auf geht's.
Wenn die alle ihre Leute nehmen
und jedem quasi
eine Pistole in die Hand drücken,
um die Dinger in den Boden zu ballern,
dann laufen die durch die Bäume durch,
durch die Wälder durch und ballern das Zeug in die Erde
und dann sind die schneller fertig,
als sie das gebaut haben.
Okay, aber warum nicht? Wenigstens eine nette Idee.
So, ähm, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Geo-Mode
Raspberry Pi Based
Do-it-yourself-Touchscreen-Remote-Kit
Das ist was für mich.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Ah, yes.
Ups, ah, nein.
Sorry, das da wollte ich haben.
Warum habe ich meinen Scheißhaufen Emote direkt über
Excellent?
Ja, hier, Twitch-Zuschau-
Schauer,
da gebe ich dir prinzipiell recht.
Man muss halt bei der ganzen
Umweltthematik,
ich finde es auch schon wieder doof,
dass es sich wieder so komplett in zwei Lager
gespalten hat.
Zumindest kommt einem das so vor.
Es gibt bestimmt auch noch genug Leute in der Mitte,
aber das was du hörst, du hast so zwei Lager.
Hier, seid mal nicht so hysterisch,
hier Klima, so kann der Mensch ja eh nichts
für oder sonst was.
Du hast die anderen, die am liebsten quasi
alles erschießen würden, was nicht
ein Greta-Poster aufgehängt hat.
Aber ich finde,
man muss doch mal gucken,
also es sollte jedem klar sein,
dass es so nicht weitergehen kann.
Und man sollte sich auch nicht
nur auf eine Sache fokussieren.
Zum Beispiel, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
man muss mal gucken, wie viel Plastik im Meer
mittlerweile rumschwimmt.
Generell müssen wir mal ein bisschen
dazu hinkriegen,
oder die Kurve kriegen,
dass wir überhaupt mit allem die Umwelt
weniger verschmutzen.
Es geht nicht,
es wird sich so sehr auf
ganze CO2-Geschichte, sonst was,
fokussiert. Ich sage nicht,
dass es verkehrt ist oder schlecht wäre,
aber wir haben auch sehr viele
andere Baustellen, wo wir uns mal
ein bisschen zusammenreißen müssen.
Ich meine, man sieht das
von Satellitenbildern aus
Plastik im Meer.
Leider ist das wieder so ein Ding,
auch wieder so ein Thema,
wo wir es wieder nicht schaffen,
ordentlich darüber zu diskutieren.
Wie gesagt, die einen schreien rum
nach dem Motto, seid nicht so hysterisch,
das ist ja alles halb so wild
und der Mensch kann ja eh nichts dafür.
Wie man überhaupt auf so eine Idee kommen kann,
finde ich abwegig.
Aber die andere Seite ist auch nicht besser.
Du musst bei allen Sachen gucken,
zumindest die Leute
halbwegs mit abzuholen und halbwegs
mit zu überzeugen.
Ansonsten wirst du so viel
Widerstände, Aufstände, sonst was
kriegen und man muss
ja auch schauen, dass es nicht gerade
die ausbaden müssen, die eh schon
Pfandflaschen sammeln müssen am Hauptbahnhof.
Wann kommen eigentlich die neuen Emotes?
Bald!
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt die Raspberry Pi
selbst do it yourself
Remote an. Gibt es ein Video?
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
altes Klapphandy, oder?
Kennt ihr noch die Leute, die früher
das Klapphandy nicht mit dem Daumen
aufgeklappt haben, sondern so cool
aus dem Handgelenk so
aufflippen konnten?
Das fand ich immer nice. Das hatte so was
stylisches.
Du hast das Klapphandy nicht
aufgeklappt mit dem Daumen, sondern
hast du aufgeschüttelt das Klapphandy.
Okay, Boomer, Leute, Chat,
jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht von euch.
Ich rede über
Klapphandys. Das ist die
Gelegenheit. Chat,
ich warte da jetzt drauf. Das ist
die Gelegenheit,
dass ihr das mal wieder loswerden könnt.
Ich bin immerhin 35.
Ja, gut. Wunderbar.
Es gibt doch wieder
Klappsmartphones. Ja, gibt's
jetzt wieder. Und es wird keine
Sau kaufen, weil es übelst teuer ist und
nicht wirklich
großartig was bringt. Aber,
sobald Apple rauskommt und bringt
ein Klapphandy, dann wird's voller Erfolg.
Es muss erst mal Apple mit einem neuen
Klapphandy rauskommen, dann geht's ab.
Wobei selbst Apple kein Garant dafür ist.
Man guckt sich mal Apple Watch an.
Apple Watch.
Apple Watch. Ja.
War damals auch gehypt,
vorgestellt und im Endeffekt
außer für ein bisschen Fitness-Trackern
werden die ganzen Geschichten nicht
verwendet. Das der ist fragt,
ich weiß nicht, ob die Frage schon
gestellt wurde. Wenn du so anfängst,
garantiert.
Aber sollte man jetzt wirklich Windows 7
als Privatperson ersetzen?
Oder ist das egal, wenn
man eh den gleichen PC seit 7 Jahren
hat? Ja, auf jeden Fall
solltest du das ersetzen.
Michael, es gibt nen Emote-Channel.
Es gibt nen Emote-Channel, da kannst du's reinschreiben.
Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall, Windows 7 muss weg.
Windows 7 muss weg.
Äh. Ich dachte, wir kriegen
jetzt so ein fancy Intro-Video.
Wo ist denn da der Raspberry drin? Das ist ein
Zero, hä? Das könnte man bisher
aber auch alles ohne Probleme
mit nem ESP machen.
Ein Zero ist da drin, okay.
Ach, der ist das, das hab ich gesehen.
Den Forums-Post hab
ich gesehen. Das kenn ich.
Das hab ich mir schon mal angeguckt vor nem Jahr.
Ach, der ist das.
Das war wirklich ganz cool.
Aber ich dachte, er hat irgendwie ein cooles Video gedreht
oder so noch mittlerweile.
Das finde ich von der Idee her... Ah, hier.
Ne.
Das hat auch Erkennung, wann sich einer
benähert. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Aber, die Sache ist die, es braucht keiner mehr Fernbedienung.
Ich hab meine
Dashboard-Tablets.
Wenn ich was steuern muss.
Das einzige halt für den Fernseher, ja.
Aber ansonsten, ich glaube...
Also wenn ich wirklich Home-Automatisierung
was steuern würde, nehm ich eines der
14 Tablets, die so rumfliegen.
Das funktioniert garantiert
nicht besser, wie nen Harmony Hub
oder wie nen Logitech Harmony, weil's
do-it-yourself ist. Und die Dinger können in der Regel
standardmäßig nicht so viel, sondern
sie sind halt... Der Vorteil ist halt, dass sie
individuell anpassbar sind.
Das Open Source
würde ich mal vermuten, ja.
Ja.
Jaja, ist es, ist es. Ich hab das
Projekt im Home Assistant Forum schon vor nem
Jahr gesehen. Hier.
Touch Remote, GitHub.
100 Sterne für so ein Nischenprojekt ist nicht
verkehrt. Leute, ich muss
mal ganz kurz... Afk.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Ja, ich... Hallo und
Chat, ich beobachte euch.
Vom Handy aus. Kein Scheiß machen.
Chat, ich hab für euch
ein Rätsel.
Ich hab für euch ein Rätsel.
Und zwar, passt mal auf.
Wer kann mir erklären,
was dieser C++ Code macht?
So.
Auf geht's.
Was macht das? Das ist auch ordentlich formatiert.
Was macht das? Ich hab das
1 zu 1 von Stack Overflow
kopiert.
Und ich habe
legit keine Ahnung,
was es macht.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich weiß, was rauskommt.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung,
was es macht. Was ist das?
Was macht es?
Jedes Mal, wenn ich was
C++-mäßiges suchen muss,
was ganz einfaches,
ja. Wenn ich denke,
es muss doch recht easy sein.
Und dann suche ich danach, wie man Sachen
in C++ macht. Und das erste, was ich
finde, sind Stack Overflow-Einträge,
wo Leute irgendwelche Hacks vorschlagen,
weil die einfachsten Sachen nicht ordentlich funktionieren,
in dieser Kacksprache.
Es ist die beschissenste Programmiersprache
auf dieser, naja,
okay, es gibt schlimmere, aber
eine der schlimmsten Programmiersprachen ever.
Lieber zwei Zeilen mehr
und übersichtlicher.
Also, Chat,
ich sehe auch, ihr habt keine Ahnung.
Vor allem, was zum Geier ist das hier?
Ich kapiere ja alles.
Das hier ist die Zeile,
die ich nicht verstehe.
C++ ist so ein,
eine hässliche Ausgeburt
der Hölle mittlerweile.
Du suchst dir einfach
Sachen raus und musst erst mal 20 Seiten
Templates schreiben in C++.
So eine Kacksprache.
Ich wollte es euch nochmal zeigen, weil das richtig eklig ist.
Bäh, geh weg.
Ekliges Zeug.
Kannst du den Code kopieren und einen Link verschütten?
Nö.
Was da rauskommt,
das ist schwierig zu erklären
ohne den Kontext.
Kann ich so nicht erklären.
Guckst du dir so Zeugs an,
wenn du kackst?
Nee.
Also, ehrlich gesagt, gerade, wo ich kacken war,
habe ich mir den Twitch-Chat angeguckt,
weil ich wissen wollte,
was der Chat macht, während ich weg bin.
Den Code kann man nicht ausführen,
das ist ein Template,
das eine Funktion anlegt,
die noch aufgerufen werden muss.
Ansonsten,
ich habe hier ein paar Stapel-CTs liegen,
die ich mal lesen müsste.
Ich habe ja ein CT-Abo seit Jahren,
also wirklich 10, 15,
ewig habe ich ein CT-Abo,
ewig, wirklich ewig.
15 Jahre, locker, habe ich ein CT-Abo.
Und ich lese davon nichts.
Die stapeln sich einfach nur dies und vor.
Warum dann noch ein Abo?
Tja,
weil ich zu faul bin gewesen,
es zu kündigen bisher.
Ich habe noch eine Gamestar-CD von 1997.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Power and endurance.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Protect your transmission and gearbox with...
What?
Was heißt das?
Man kann damit alte Sachen wieder neu machen?
Soll das das heißen?
Okay.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Alte Getriebe, ja.
Erst mal eines der größten Projekte
der Menschheitsgeschichte.
If you're a dreamer like us,
the magic of flying machines
still inspires you.
We are Tribotex,
the makers of a revolutionary nanotechnology
that reverses wear.
Our innovation reached the final frontier
in the fight against friction,
superlubricity.
With the success of our first Kickstarter,
tens of thousands of people
have joined the cause for superior lubrication
than only Bruce's performance.
Das klingt falsch.
Das klingt falsch, was der sagt.
Improves fuel economy and extends longevity
but actually reverses wear.
We started our journey...
What?
...designing clean lubricants for wind turbines.
And now we are returning to the sky.
Since the beginning
we set our sights on flight.
This is no small dream.
Aviation standards
are more rigorous
than any other industry.
When our technology
is used in the field
of flying machines,
it will be used everywhere.
Planes are built to last.
But the key to dependability
is upgrading components over time.
Today we use the same aviation-grade lube
that was made when MASH
was on the air.
Are we going to let them do this to us?
No, I say no!
Here's where you come in. Partner with us
and the United States Air Force
to take a quantum leap forward
and formulate the most advanced gearbox lubricant
machines.
Gearbox failure is a nightmare
for pilots, aircraft mechanics
and everyday people.
A dead transmission
costs you thousands of dollars
even if you can repair it yourself.
It will take us a few years
to make it work.
I'm waiting for them to tell us
how it works.
Yes, that's right.
That's what I'm thinking.
They should tell us
how it works.
That's why we're releasing
an ATF treatment
that restores your gearbox
to a better than you condition
with diamond-like gamma
on critical components
forged by carbon
That's the idea
with motorspring.
to protect vulnerable surfaces.
The grippy side binds your machine
to protect and strengthen.
The slippery side reduces friction
to super-lubricity levels,
enhancing performance and efficiency.
This powerful little particle
won the 2017 Defense Innovation Award,
the 2018 Indiegogo Innovative Product Award
and an Air Force SBIR Phase 1 Award.
Tribotex offers already
engine treatment
I don't have any plastic shimmers
but really an explanation
for people
who want to bake it
but don't just eat it
that's the best ever
would be not bad
explain to us how it works
for all kinds of machines
whether you drive a motorcycle
hybrid or 18-wheeler
you can be more efficient
In fact, Tribotex isn't just
about engines and machines
Friction is a problem
that affects everyone
from the machines we depend on
to the fuel we consume
back on campaign and together
whether that's reputation
for the new millennium
and make our world more efficient
more powerful and more sustainable
You do not have to fly
to use this technology
but with your help
we will take it to the sky above
and beyond
Okay, backed by science
If I have to write that in
sounds like a scam
So if someone
backed by science
and basically
doesn't tell anything about it
Diamond like armor
Made in Kokona
Okay
Ah
I don't know
So if I had the choice
left side and right side
Then it would be a deal
somehow
But I think
so really
I don't leave it
to my car
Where my car
because everything is lost
Okay, next
We have remote control
City Maps
Oh yeah
So projects
go in the
pants
But we have to look at it
Have you read something about
Thunderbolt 4
Why
Should Thunderbolt
now not flow into USB
and Thunderbolt
fall away with USB 4
No Fiat
I've already shown you
my huge car
Yes
Best
Green
Huge
Es ist für die Klasse
tatsächlich huge
Ja schon
diese Farbe hier
Ich war schon Agile
bevor das angesagt war
Kennzeichen liegt
GG
GG thanks Ray
Nein habe ich nicht mitgekriegt
Und zu Thunderbolt 4
habe ich auch nichts gelesen
Okay
So
Das sind so diese Kickstarter Projekte
wo ich mir immer so denke
Ja selbst wenn am Ende was fertiges rauskommt
Meistens sind nicht das
Also es gibt
Mir fallen wenig Beispiele ein
wo diese Sachen immer erfolgreich
erfolgreich gewesen sind
Das sind das größte Negativbeispiel
jetzt nicht aus dieser Branche
aus anderen ist ja immer noch Star Citizen
Ja weiß ich wie es mit
wie steht es so um Star Citizen
Ich habe gehört 2020 erscheint angeblich die Kampagne
Es gibt nicht viele richtig erfolgreiche
Kickstarter Sachen in der Größe hier
IP Leaked
Wo denn jetzt schon wieder
Hier irgendwo IP Leaked
Da IP Leaked oh shit
Fuck Alter IP Leaked
OMG IP Leaked
Wenn man auf dieser IP gelegt
Kommt man in meinem Meme Board raus
Easy
So sieht das aus wenn ich vom zweiten Monitor aus
bediene
Ihr seht das bloß immer nicht
KJTHT
SamuSKRiMER
Nice
Kennst du Crowd Supply?
Hotkeys habe ich auch zum Beispiel
M L das
BG habe ich nicht mehr
Nicht so viel
Ok das Self Balancing Scooter also
Hast du das Dashboard
Im Stream programmiert
Ein bisschen
Teilweise haben wir es im Stream gemacht
We Spent
Ich meine, man könnte auch einfach sich einen normalen E-Roller holen
und das einfach an einem Fahrradständer abstellen oder so.
Geht auch, ja.
Überlegt euch mal, ihr wollt in Saturn rein
und habt so ein Ding dabei.
Die lassen euch da dann rein.
Die haben ja eh komplette Paranoia beim Saturn am Eingang.
Ist euch das mal aufgefallen?
Egal was du mit reinnehmen willst,
wollen sie dich nicht mit reinleben lassen.
Und ich lasse meinen Rucksack mit Inhalten,
da ist nicht irgendwelchen Security-Menschen.
Wieso auch in Saturn wollen wir das eigentlich nicht?
Kackler!
Der hat aber...
Laufen hat er geübt, oder?
Der läuft sehr cool und lässig mit diesem Ding, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an!
Passt mal auf jetzt!
Guckt mal!
Jetzt hier!
Guckt mal, wie cool er damit langläuft!
Oh, immer diese Kokona-Units!
Was sind denn zwölf Meilen?
Die Reifen sind ziemlich klein.
Die Reifen sind ziemlich klein und dünn.
Deswegen sieht das auch so wackelig aus.
Bei uns in Frankfurt stehen an jeder Ecke so Dinge rum zu mieten.
Die sind eigentlich ganz cool.
Aber die erhöhen...
Du kannst quasi zugucken, wie die...
Nicht nur Leimroller, es gibt drei Stück, die da rumstehen.
Es gibt so orange, es gibt grüne und es gibt blau...
Gelbe.
Ist aber ganz nice.
Aber sie werden immer...
Also sie werden...
Du kannst quasi zugucken, wie der Teuateyou teurer wird.
...
Okay, das war damit großartig.
Es ist...
Es ist schon ganz schön wackelig.
Das da oben bricht ab.
Das bricht ab.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt mal.
Das bricht ab.
Da mal ordentlich dran gerüttelt.
Wenn es das mal ordentlich durchrüttelt.
Wenn mal irgendwie was ist.
Du fliegst aufs Maul oder du fährst gegen so ein Bordschein.
Das bricht ab.
Da oben.
Gerade da auch, wo das Gelenk ist.
Nicht Aluminium.
Dann bricht es vielleicht nicht ab, sondern verbiegt sich, sodass du nichts mehr damit machen kannst.
Also das sieht nicht so stabil aus.
Generell, es sieht halt aus, als ist es auf fancy Optik gemacht.
Die können viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das sieht nicht sonderlich stabil aus hier oben.
Das ganze Ding.
Ist mehr wert als ein Opel, garantiert.
Für mein Opel muss ich noch Geld bezahlen, wenn ihn jemand nimmt.
Man2RX ist unangenehm und erstaunlich im E-Scooter-Markt.
Wir produzieren die erste Batsche von Man2RX.
Unser Team wächst jeden Tag.
Bitte beurteilen unsere Karte.
Und helfen uns, diese fantastische Innovation an die Welt zu eröffnen.
Okay, warum nicht?
Ich habe den Wahnsinnsvorteil zu einem herkömmlichen E-Roller jetzt noch nicht erkannt.
Klar, man kann das mitnehmen und eben an sich herfahren.
Aber die anderen Dinger kannst du auch...
Damit fährst du ja nicht durch die Stadt.
Da fährst du damit hin, wo du hin willst.
Und dann kannst du ihn ja immer noch beispielsweise an irgendeinem Fahrradständer oder so festmachen.
Habe ich auch nie ausprobiert, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Wie viel kostet der?
339 Dollar, das ist ganz schön billig.
Das ist ziemlich günstig.
Was kostet so ein ordentlicher E-Roller?
Wie heißt...
Elektroroller.
Das sind eher die Preise, wo ich hier sagen würde, in dem bewegen wir uns.
Expected Retail Price.
So, wie sieht denn aus die zeitliche Abfolge, wie die das machen wollen?
Äh, hier.
Estimated...
Wo steht es denn?
Delivery.
Wo steht es denn, wann die fertig sind?
März 20...
Boah, das ist ja nicht mal lang.
100 Kilo Maximum Payload.
Leute, es wird eng.
Es wird eng.
Erstmal auf die Waage stellen.
Nein, Asien, kein Problem.
Das hier oben sieht null stabil aus.
Ich sag's jetzt zum 25. Mal, ich weiß, aber das sieht...
Äh, mal gucken.
Mal gucken.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
World's First Laser Masher Tool.
Ist nicht normal, dass man Entfernungen mittlerweile mit Laser misst.
Das sieht aus wie AliExpress.
Diese Musik immer!
Was?
Voice Broadcast?
Was ist Voice Broadcast?
Ah, ist das, ist das, wenn ich quasi mit zwei Leuten kommunizieren will?
Ne, äh, Flo96 war ich.
Ich hab abgenommen, weil ich hab heute nichts gegessen.
Also, heute Mittag nicht.
Oh, huge voice.
Versteht man sehr gut, oder?
Ich denke, ihr versteht auch alles.
Habt ihr das verstanden?
Alles klar.
Ah, yes.
Es ist doch AliExpress.
My Antenna?
Make Pro Tools easy to use.
Was?
So was gibt's doch schon.
Ist doch nichts Neues.
Es ist eine der Werkzeuge, die ich doch nicht besitze.
Ja, aber so was gibt's doch schon.
Seid mal hier, Link, Chat.
Ja, genau, so war's im Prinzip, ja.
Ich find diese Bosch-Bilder immer so geil, äh.
Haben sie irgendeinen Typ hingestellt, so nach dem Motto, zieh dir mal sowas, zieh dir mal einen Plaumann an und dann, äh, machen wir mal ein schönes Foto.
Sie hätten diesen Haha-Typ nehmen müssen.
Diesen, diesen, diesen mit den weißen Haaren, der so grinst.
Wie heißt denn der?
Der Meme-Opa.
Ja, Harald, Harald, genau, genau der.
Genau der, den mein ich.
Turn your iPad Pro into a Mac...
Ah, ja.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Das ist ja ein sehr vollmundiges Versprechen.
Ich mein, es ist eine Notebook, es ist quasi eine Notebook-Halterung, wo man ein iPad reinclipsen kann, ja.
Ähm.
Ähm, dadurch wird das iPad noch lange nicht zum MacBook Pro.
Aber, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, was wir uns erzählen wollen.
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen?
China, AliExpress, können wir schon, können wir es bestellen demnächst.
Doku, Doku, Doko, Dokio, kann ich das nicht mehr aussprechen?
Erstmal, schön programmieren ohne Syntax-Highlighting.
Das müssen wir mal genauer analysieren, Leute.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine, für eine hässliche...
Für eine hässliche Editor?
Void?
Z-Display?
Capable?
Virtual Void?
Das ist C++?
Igitt!
Das ist C++ und dann auch noch Syntax, ohne Syntax-Highlighting.
Das ist, das ist keine...
Das sieht nicht, das sieht nicht...
Ne, das sieht nicht nach Arduino-Zeugs aus.
Also wieder 5G.
Über USB-3.
Wenn ihr 0 kriegen will, das will ich sehen.
Das will ich sehen.
Never.
Geht gar nicht.
Gar nicht drin.
Also von der Bedienung her ist es, glaube ich, mit Tastatur richtig kacke.
Ich hab das ja mal ausprobiert.
Ich hab mir mal, ich hab mir ja so, gibt's ja, gibt's ja, kannst ja machen.
Äh, Tastatur, ne Tastatur geholt fürs iPad.
Lohnt sich 0.
Ich hab gedacht, das ist ganz praktisch, wenn man ein bisschen was längeres drauf tippen will, macht man...
Es ist voll für den Arsch.
Es ist komplett wasted.
Und das wahrscheinlich auch.
Kriegst nie im Leben 5 Gigabit über, über USB-3.0.
Nie.
Ich glaub, 480 ist Maximum, was theoretisch geht.
Ähm, 3.0 und das ist auch noch theoretisches USB-Maximum.
Und das sind, das ist in, in, ähm...
Achso, 480, 480 sind 2.
Du kriegst trotzdem kein 5 Gigabit über, über USB-3.0.
Kein Fall.
Nie und nimmer.
Ja.
Guck, du kriegst, du kriegst, Moment, das ist, das ist 1x1, Sam.
Du kriegst 5 Gigabit, hast du maximale, im optimalsten Fall, ähm, USB-Geschwindigkeit.
Und da kriegst du im Leben keine 5 Gigabit drüber, im Leben nicht.
Da kannst du locker nochmal ein Drittel abziehen von.
Ja gut, natürlich, ich kann, kann ein Port dran machen, der 5G-Link bekommt irgendwie, ja.
Aber da nicht 5G übertragen.
Lest da drunter, was soll ich lesen?
Hier, Superspeed USB.
Gut, das heißt ja doch nix.
Das ist, was du damit maximal theoretisch machen könntest.
Aber, das ist quasi, wenn du, wenn du 1 zu 1 Bits von A nach B, ohne jegliche Protokolle, ohne jegliche andere Sachen, übertragen könntest.
Kannst du ja nicht.
Das kriegst du nie, kriegst du nie im Leben drüber über 3.0.
USB 3.0.
Maximum SSD.
Guck mal mal.
Gibt's da, gibt's da, gibt's da irgendeinen Test für?
Slower than SATA, ja auf jeden Fall.
Ja, Chip.
Mein, die Seite meines Vertrauens.
Das ist aber kein 2x2.
Test.
Hier.
Chip.
Hallo?
Tabelle.
Tom's Hardware, das geht ja noch.
Du musst aber halt gucken, dass es auch USB 3.0 ist.
Alter, mach doch einfach, mach doch irgendjemand mal eine Tabelle.
Mach doch eine Tabelle dahin.
So.
Und das ist schon ne neuere.
Das ist schon ne neuere.
500 Gigabit, also Taschenrechner, das ist 1 Gigabit mal 5, so 625 gehen, 400 geht durch.
Ja jetzt red dich mal nicht raus.
Du hast gesagt kein Problem und jetzt sagst du braucht man doch nicht.
Ich sag geht nicht.
Das theoretische Max, das ist, das ist ein bisschen eine Tatsache.
Ja, gut.
bisschen wie bei PCI Express.
PCI Express geht auch viel, viel
mehr, als theoretisch dann wirklich
an Daten nutzbar drüber geht.
Das ist, wenn du Netzwerkkarte
oder sonst was über USB machst, auch so.
So, gucken wir mal
weiter, wie die das
iPad zum MacBook machen.
Oh, man kann das chargen, das geht ja so
gar nicht. Oh, das ist noch schneller.
Jetzt sind wir bei
USB 3.1.
Ja, Flow 96, exakt das gleiche
sag ich doch auch.
Jetzt, du hast am Anfang
gesagt, das packt 5 Gigabit.
Packt das nicht. 400 Megabyte sind keine
5 Gigabit. Jetzt kann man
ganz einfach umrechnen.
5 Gigabit sind irgendwie
650 und keine 400.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Also, ich
behaupte mal, es ist komplett useless,
das Ding.
Eiskräuter ist doch ganz einfach. USB 3.0
ist das gleiche wie USB
3.2 1x1.
Oh, guck mal, der guckt wirdscher.
Der Switcher.
Das ist komplett useless,
das Ding.
Netflix Copyright Strike.
Genau. Ne, das ist wirklich komplett useless
gewesen. Ne, Hosen,
nein. Nach dem
Scam, wo sie mich mit der
Hose gescamt haben, nochmal
bestelle ich mir keine Hose bei Kickstarter.
Der Ananas-Stepper.
Das könnte praktisch
sein.
Zum Beispiel für
ähm
Fensterblenden oder
hm.
Für was kann man es gebrauchen? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hosenscam, ja.
Ich hab mal für 150 Dollar
so eine, so eine selbst
oder sag mal so, keine selbstreinigende
Jeans, sondern eine Jeans gebackt,
die quasi wasserabweisende
Partikel drinne hat und deswegen
nicht so schnell dreckig wird.
Und halt keine Flecken drinne bleiben.
Und
die wurde halt nie ausgeliefert.
Der Ananas-Stepper.
Ah, für
3D-Drucker.
Ne, Void-Danny
hab ich noch nicht probiert.
Und, und Fräse.
Ach, dafür ist das
da. Okay.
Huge, huge
äh, Voice Acting.
Aber guten Namen hat's, guten Namen hat's.
Muss man ihnen lassen.
Der Ananas-Stepper.
Sieht aus wie ein von mir,
heh.
Titt.
Sieht aus,
warte, warte.
Sieht aus wie ein von mir zusammengelötetes Board,
Alter.
Hehehe.
Nein, es sieht besser aus, aber
hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
...Ladies Version
to the Rhone-An-Kickstarter.
We are happy to introduce
Ananas-Stepper 3.0.
An open source, modularized, multifunctional, high precision.
Closed-Limit Motor.
Ananas-Stepper is closed-looper.
Ananas-Stepper uses a high precision, 15 bit TLE.
5012B.
Ich hab keine...
Ich habe kein, legit.
Keine Ahnung, wovon er spricht.
Aber das liegt an mir, nicht an ihm.
Wahrscheinlich ist das für Leute, die wissen, was sie brauchen,
was richtig cool ist.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, von was er spricht.
Wow!
Slap!
Das ist das SMD, keine Lutschstelle.
Das haben sie mit dem Föhn drauf gemacht, mit dem Eisluftfön.
Ananastepfer? Ich mach den Namen, der gefällt mir.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Kein blassen Schimmer, wozu ich den Ananastepfer gebrauchen könnte.
Und ich habe hier schon viel Automatisierungsgedöns.
Keine Ahnung.
Bisher den Ananastepfer habe ich so noch nicht erkannt, dass ich den brauche.
Der Name ist toll. Brauchen die noch Geld?
Ne, brauchen nicht. Okay.
Ananastepfer.
Heißt das nicht Pineapple in dem Fall, heißt das Ananas.
In hohem Procedural Quality.
Und dergines
Xbox Ananas.
Würden ihre Xbox Ananas nennen, das würde sich verkaufen wie.
Wie PS5.
In Deutschland.
Ananastepfer ist multifunktional.
Ananastepfer kommt mit einer Vagina.
Das ist Visual Studio Code.
Und das könnte jetzt. Das ist normales C.
normales c die zumindest von der syntax also aus dem world links links ohne
irgendwas drum herum und aber auch was anderes sein
dieses c++ hier cpp punkt h was mit dem micro usb interface
die computer oder raspberry pi das habe ich so auch noch nicht gehört
und der action pause interface you can directly replace the stepper motor on
your 3d printer and desktop cnc you can even put hundreds of anna stepper
motors in series using an rs485 bus or c8n bus to realize your creative ideas
want to create a robot arm or a cocktail machine
okay flo 690 ist geforscht wow moment moment
siehst du jetzt habe ich das
stepper modus auf dem 3d printer und desktop cnc
das ist das das beste wieder nicht nicht gesehen
pater weinberg
thinking in e 지난 juli es geht
to church player
einhört am 2
Der Name ist geil.
Und das Video ist auch cool.
Endlich mal ein cooles Produkt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wozu ich es jemals gebrauchen könnte, aber das gefällt mir.
Ist das eine Computerstimme?
Habe ich auch gedacht zwischendurch.
Aber Computerstimmen haben in der Regel keine, keine, ähm, keine zune Nase und keine, keine Computerstimmen klingen, klingen.
Ja, so ohne Beeinträchtigung irgendwie.
Ähm, es klingt aber ein bisschen wie ein Text-to-Speech.
Gerne ich dir recht.
Weil der auch Raspberry Pi gesagt hat.
Und C++.
Ananas-Stepper.
Huge.
Ich weiß nicht, wozu ich es brauche, aber Ananas-Stepper.
Ananas-Stepper ist nice.
Ananas.
Perfekt.
Next.
Unbeatable.
Dünne Kopfhörer mit Supreme Sound Quality.
Okay.
Also.
Eine Sache muss man ja bei Lautsprechern, kann man, man kann Lautsprecher in einer Sache ganz gut mit Autos vergleichen.
Ähm, Größe sagt tatsächlich, also mal mit dem Motor, Größe sagt tatsächlich was aus.
Also Raum ist da bei Lautsprechern durch, äh, eigentlich nur noch mehr Raum zu ersetzen.
Okay, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Die Kickstarter-Musik.
Was ist 0,1 OZ?
Ist das wieder Kokona-Einheit?
Ounces?
Sind das Ounces?
Okay, was ist das für zu Gramm?
Äh, 2, also 3 Gramm.
3 Gramm.
Ounces.
Meine Güte, ey.
Diese Einheiten.
Ah, yes.
Also, 3 Gramm.
Sehr dünn.
Irgendein Business-Dude.
Bluetooth.
Superb Vocal Clarity.
Alle immer Hipster-Apple-Zeug am Start?
Ja, ist klar.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für eine tolle, was für eine Technologie.
CD-Quality-Lossless-Audio.
Äh, das hängt, äh, immer von der Quelle ab, würde ich sagen, ne?
Es hat sogar noch ein Mikrofon drinne.
CD-Qualität, weil CD-Qualität tatsächlich nicht schlecht ist.
Hat mich jetzt nicht so angesprochen.
War das da Google Assistant Logo?
Ja.
Google Assistant Logo.
Hab ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt.
Aber hat mich jetzt nicht so, nicht so angesprochen, ehrlich gesagt.
Dann, dann hol ich mir lieber den Ananas-Stepper.
Gucken wir uns nicht an.
Der Kräutergarten.
Wer wollte sich noch schon immer nicht mal, nicht schon immer den Kräutergarten daheim
hinstellen?
Spricht mich jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig an.
Black Beast Pro.
Nochmal ne Docking Station.
Turn your Desktop into, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Turn your Laptop in a Desktop Powerhouse.
Made in Norway.
The Laptop.
Aber, es ist wirklich so, die, diese Kickstarter-Videos werden doch garantiert von nem gleichen Hersteller
produziert, oder?
Es ist die gleiche Aufmachung, die gleiche Musik, gefühlt die gleichen Leute, sind nicht
die gleichen Leute, aber die sehen alle sehr ähnlich aus.
Das sieht alles, ähm, alles sehr gleich in der Aufmachung immer aus.
Wieder ein Laptop.
Oh, oh hier.
Huge.
Erstmal CS-Knifen.
Hat die nen Skin?
Guck.
Erstmal checken, ob die, ob die nen Handschuh-Skin hat, nen Messerskin.
Ah, na, na, na, das ist, das geht aber so nicht.
Das ist, das ist ziemlich, das ist ziemlich nubig, oder?
So'n komisches, fast Standard-Knife und keine, keine ordentlichen Handschuhe.
Auch noch gegen Bots?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist, das ist die Map, wo sie letztens in diesem einen Turnier die, die Bombe in die
Wand geklitscht haben.
Was'n das?
15 FPS.
Alter, wie viel FPS waren das bitteschön gerade?
Hat, okay, angeblich 118, hat nicht ausgesehen wie 118.
Okay, wir wollen dir das machen.
Lotta.
Kennt jemand Lotta?
Oh, ja, ja, stimmt.
Twitch.
Lotta.
18K, mehr als 18K.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
So, jetzt.
Warte.
Jetzt.
18K mehr als ich, na klar.
Darf ich nichts sagen.
Bestimmt die Freundin vom Kunde, oder so.
Ja, ist das?
Ist, ist, ist da, ist da ne Grafikkarte drin?
Und es wird einfach.
Oder was?
Was, was ist das denn überhaupt?
Cool.
grafikkarte ja ja ja und wie schließt man das an
es ist wie wenn man sich einfach ein desktop kauft
einfach desktop kaufen
er war ein großer mann nicht nur wo ich das ding mit hinnehmen
blablabla ein bisschen was
ok es ist es ist quasi es ist ein grafikkartengehäuse was man über
was auch immer genau anschließt dann braucht man wahrscheinlich noch die
passenden hersteller treiber dass das ordentlich funktioniert das funktioniert
da bin ich ganz sicher dass das funktioniert und ich bin sehr froh dass
das funktioniert und ich bin sehr froh dass
ich zuversichtlich dass es funktioniert das ist ja nichts neues
aber wie irgendjemand schon im chat gesagt hat damit gibt es auf das
probleme
könnte sicher wenn man wenn man so speed haben will für quasi desktop video
editing dann stelle ich mir noch da wirklich den desktop rechner hin
die up coming usb 4 und die dual controller ins spiel spiel von der bolt
and thunderbolt 2 support
14 ports like beast pro meets your needs
packing 10 gigabit ethernet port
ah ja ok es ist im endeffekt eine grafikkarte plus noch ein bisschen andere anschlüsse
warum nicht wenn man es braucht
ich würde mal einen desktop computer hinstellen
warum nicht
designed developed and made in norway
wieviel kostet das denn?
253 euro aber da musst du ja wahrscheinlich noch die grafikkarte dabei
dabei kaufen die sind ja da nicht drin
kriegst wahrscheinlich nur das gehäuse ohne dass irgendwas großartig dran ist
einfach einfach desktop hinstellen und gut ist
das ist alles nur eine krücke
personal alarm designed to save lives
aha kann mit gps nichts tracken
gps ist read only
our lives are defined to save lives
our lives are defined by the things that we hold most precious
the people that make all the difference
then isn't it worth asking the question
what if there were a device a simple smart and effective alarm
that made sure our loved ones are safe and protected
so for the people who make a difference
we might not have to ask ourselves what we could have done differently
that's why alpha home has created the care go
alpha home?
a personal alarm system designed to save lives
home
by simply connecting the device to your phone
it helps protect personal safety
and makes sure your loved ones are ready
was passiert denn wenn ich gerade mal zufällig
mein internettarif ausgelaugt
mein volumen aufgebraucht ist
ich mein man kann es trotzdem übertragen
und das braucht bestimmt nicht viel bandbreite
aber deutschland netzabdeckung und so
care go
a simple twist
and you've activated follow me mode
when you're in an uncertain situation
the protectors that you list are notified
and they'll be shown in real time
man muss dafür
jetzt mal nur mal dass ich es verstehe
man muss dafür sein handy dabei haben
aber
mein handy hat doch schon gps
warum brauche ich nochmal ein extra gps
also wofür
jetzt ernst gemeinte frage
ich will jetzt echt nicht schlecht
wofür braucht man das denn
ich muss mein handy dabei haben
dass ich quasi updates senden kann
aber wenn ich mein handy dabei habe
habe ich doch schon gps
habe ich doch schon die möglichkeit
gps zu empfangen und updates zu senden
ja du musst dein smartphone
alter natürlich meine ich smartphone
your location on a map
care go is easy enough for your kids to use too
so they never feel like they're alone
quatsch handy gps ist top
you can easily send an alert by simply pulling the care go
ja ok das ist
das ist zu hause verstehe ich das
wenn man das zu hause umhängen hat
mein opa hatte auch so einen alarmknopf
ja
aber unterwegs dann hast du
du hast doch eh ein smartphone dabei
ja
wow
willst
ja
we
mehr
mal
ja
Was wird denn da drin sein? Wenn es hochkommt, eine 250 mAh Batterie oder sowas?
Niemals ein Ja, wenn man das regelmäßig verwendet.
Es ist im Prinzip ein Notrufknopf.
Ja, warum nicht?
Wobei ich halt der Einsicht bin, es hängt von ein bisschen zu vielen Faktoren ab.
Du hast, also die ganze Hausnotrufgeschichte ist halt auch so raufgelegt, dass sie halt verpflichtend funktionieren muss vom jeweiligen Anbieter aus.
Achso, was kostet der denn?
28 Euro?
Also mir wäre es zu unsicher.
Also wenn mein Opa noch leben würde und wenn er wirklich sowas bräuchte, du brauchst ein Smartphone oder vielleicht auch WLAN, aber mit WLAN definitiv.
Kein Never, ein Ja, niemals.
Du brauchst, der Internetanschluss muss funktionieren oder ein Smartphone da sein.
Das ist von relativ vielen Faktoren abhängig, vor allem unterwegs, wo ich mich nicht so hundertprozentig drauf verlassen würde.
Was nur iPhone-only anhand schon.
Ach, die Realität.
Gewehe oder was auch immer.
Klingt französisch, gucken wir uns nicht an.
Marscat, oh, huge.
Das brauch ich.
Da hat Chico was zum Spielen.
Da kann Chico mit der Roboterkatze spielen.
Die muss übrigens nicht anfauchen.
Willkommen in der Zukunftswelt.
Kombiniert mit advanced technology, liberal art und humanities.
Ein unglaubliches neues Zukunftsbild ist geboren.
Just like a real cat.
Marscat is fully autonomous.
Okay, also, ich hab vorhin meine Katze spielen sehen, die sah etwas eleganter aus.
Retching, tapping and even burying litter.
It may express different emotions by different meows or gestures.
Marscat can play with you or your toys because it can feel.
Naja.
Go sleep.
And see.
Wie wärs mit ner echten Katze?
Wie wärs mit ner Katze?
Ich mein, wenn man, wenn man ne Katze haben will, mit der, wenn man, mit, na, wie wärs mit ner Katze?
Weil, da tut man wenigstens auch mal was Gutes.
Die Katzen nicht.
Wenn man aufpasst.
Even play with real cats.
It heals with purr sounds.
Die sieht aber nicht so glücklich aus.
Every wild cat is unique. From its eyes, body to personality.
You can pet it and shape its characters in your own way.
Dress it up. Make it more adorable.
Oh yeah.
Marscat is open sourced and programmable.
Huge.
Guckt mal, wie super, wie toll die Katze spielt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Marscat is open sourced and programmable.
Powerful quad core raspberry pi.
You can create your own application.
Pi 4 ist da drinne.
Marscat is also an ideal choice for education, research, research.
And commercial purpose.
Open source Katze.
Batteries last for around 3 hours for active reactions.
Or 6 hours for regular motions.
Also, die ist überhaupt nicht autonom.
Die hält nur 3 Stunden.
Ja, das bringt ja auch nix.
Wenn, wenn ich sowas holen würde, würde ich sowas holen, dass es daheim rumlaufen kann.
Und mit meiner Katze ein bisschen interagiert.
Dass sie sich nicht langweilt.
We value your privacy.
And all do you need.
And all data is stored offline.
Join us for a new era of technology.
Dream up a new world.
Break the boundaries.
And embrace the future.
The Marscat has been designed for you.
Elephant Robotics.
Enjoy robots world.
So?
Weiß nicht.
World's first Apple MFI certified...
Moment, ne SSD-Karte für...
Ne SSD-Karte für...
...iPhones?
Naja, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Wall-Sun hatten wir schon.
Den Trier auch, das auch.
Nanobook.
Stonepaper.
Aber warum? Wieso?
Weshalb?
Warum ist es da?
Hm...
Äh...
Warum brennt es eigentlich,
wenn es feuerresistent ist?
Also wenn das nicht brennt,
warum brennt es?
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Warum brennt es, wenn es nicht brennt?
Das war Benzin.
Ah ja, ein bisschen vom...
...vom Feuerzeug, ja.
Äh...
Nee.
Moment, guckt es euch mal an.
Das sieht irgendwie...
...irgendwie merkwürdig aus.
Ich weiß nicht, also...
...ne.
Da bleibe ich doch lieber bei meiner echten Katze.
Bluetooth Audio Classes.
Immersive Audio Visual Protection.
Audio Cl...
Im...
Ich versuche gerade diese zwei Wörter...
...in Einklang zu bringen.
Immersive Audio Visual Protection.
Hast du einen Lautsprecher auf dem Ohr...
...oder was soll das sein?
Meet Mutrix GB30.
The world's first pair of smart glasses...
...that are developed with gamers welfare at heart.
What the hell?
Starting with this retro touch embodied in this exclusive design...
...which is reminiscent of the classic handheld console.
Das ist ne Konsole?
Mutrix GB30's exclusive audio technology...
...NFSS, or Near Field Surround System...
...delivers rich and immersive stereo sound.
So now you're able to listen and judge...
...direction of footsteps...
Im Leben!
Im Leben ist das kein ordentliches Audio...
...was da rauskommt.
Alternativ kann ich mir einfach...
...In-Ears anziehen und alles ist gut.
...delivers rich and immersive stereo sound.
So now you're able to listen and judge...
...direction of footsteps, gunshot distance...
...and locations more precisely.
Ne, ich kann mir einfach In-Ears anziehen.
Das
Okay, wer's brauch...
Das Ding ist nach 3x drücken...
...kaputt. Wenn ich mir den Knopf da an+.
guckt. Erstmal Fortnite. Wie viel? Vier Stunden? Das ist ja nix. Vier Stunden? Da kann ich mich
mal auf die Arbeit aufsetzen. Das ist zur Mittagspause leer. Das ist ein Schwachsinn.
Das ist super krass finanziert. Also, ich weiß ja nicht. World's smallest phone. Das
juckt mich jetzt nicht so, ehrlich gesagt. Tiny high speed drive fits on your...
So viele Zellen können... Ein Terabyte passt da angeblich rein. Ah ja. Wie schaffen die
das mit den Zellen für den Flash, wenn das ordentliche Flash-Zellen sind? Jo, warum nicht?
Es hat schon seinen Grund, warum der SSD, wenn die ordentliche Zellen hat, schon eine
gewisse Größe hat. Es gibt schon lange USB-Sticks, aber das ist ja angeblich eine richtige SSD.
Wenn Flash... Flash-Speicher... Ja, es ist alles Flash-Speicher. Flash-Speicher ist
das alles. Aber eine SSD hat erstens Reservekapazität, zweitens auch Zellen, die du besser, also
öfters wieder beschreiben kannst und generell eine deutlich höhere Haltbarkeit als beispielsweise
eine Micro-SD-Karte oder ein USB-Stick. Und außerdem ist sie schneller. Zwei Terabyte.
Zwei Terabyte. Also das ist im Endeffekt... Im Endeffekt eine Micro-SD-Karte als USB-Stick.
Oh, ganz schön... Ganz schön... Ganz schön billig. Also dem würde ich meine Daten nicht
anvertrauen. Es ist... Ja, aber naja, Micro-SD-Karten in der Größe sind verdammt teuer. Ja, guckt
euch das mal an. Ein Terabyte Micro-SD-Karte. Und selbst eine Micro-SD-Karte ist nicht so
teuer. Eine Micro-SD-Karte würde ich auf Dauer nicht allzu viel anvertrauen. 99 Dollar
ist ganz schön, ganz schön billig. Also dem würde ich keine Daten anvertrauen, dem
Zeug. Und booten würde ich davon schon mal gar nichts. Das ist dann nach Parma-Kleirip.
USB-Sticks mit zwei Terabyte. Ah, das sind... Das sind... Das sind aber auch eher in Richtung
richtigen Flash-Speicher. China. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte.
Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte.
Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Zwei Terabyte. Legit. Legit zwei Terabyte. Also
das ist schon ganz schön 94. Nie. Nie im Leben. Glaube ich nicht.
Sind halt in diesen Videos, sie sehen alle immer so bis zu Stahl aus. Nee,2020, also
20.1. Januar.
Total was ist,
tbw noch mal
terabytes written, genau
4000 terabytes written
das erscheint mir jetzt
ein bisschen viel
für so ein Ding, wo will denn das
was hat denn das da für einen
magic controller drin und wie viel Reserve
und naja, das glaube ich nicht
das glaube ich nicht, das ist so
ein typisches Produkt, das glaube ich
erst, wenn es irgendeine vertrauenswürdige
Seite getestet hat
was haben wir, the if coding is child play
toy robots to teach
coding, ok, also
programmieren lernen für Kinder
da bin ich ja immer dafür, für sowas
sieht ein bisschen aus wie das PHP Logo
was ist das PHP Logo, aber
aber falschrum
ist das jetzt im Trend
educational toy
to teach coding to children
from the early age of three
we know that programming
is the language of the future
and today's children need to be ready
to learn it
our solution is a simple and inclusive
toy, so that kids
can play while learning
and develop their most
genauso
so wird es in echt sein
in der Vorschule
sitzen sie im Labor
mhm
und vor allem in Deutschland
na klar
und vor allem in Deutschland, na klar
important skill, creativity
at the same time
we call them the ifs
es wäre cool, aber wenn wir die sind
there are a small family of interconnected robots
that are full of sensors and actuators
and are able to do anything within the scope of imagination
but what exactly can they do?
anything from measuring movements
light, sound, temperature and humidity
to speaking, singing, imitating, vibrating and lighting up
da ist bestimmt nur das P32 drin
what's more, they can communicate with each other and work in a team
they also have special powers
Emma is a chameleon and changes colors so that nobody can see her
Liam detects intruders in a flash to protect his family
Noah goes everywhere, always getting into trouble
Holly is able to express all of her emotions
so it's best not to make her angry
the ifs can be programmed by children
even if they don't know how to read
by placing different colored pieces on their heads
with the help of magnets to give them a sense of reality
the pieces can be combined
this is a cool idea
if something happens
then something else
will occur in consequence
No cables, no screens
Just interaction
You may not know what we mean
so let's look at an example
Verstehen Sie, dass wir nicht genug Licht haben, um zu lesen.
Wir benutzen ein Stück für, wenn es nicht Licht gibt, und ein weiteres Stück für, wenn es nicht Licht gibt, um zu lächeln.
Und jetzt haben wir unsere eigene Lampe.
Diese Toys sind für das Lernen, aber auch für die Mischung.
Lass uns ein bisschen Programmieren hier, ein bisschen Programmieren da.
Und jetzt, nur durch Emma zu schämen, wird sie Noah nennen, damit er einen erstaunlichen Geräusch macht.
Und es gibt hunderten von Möglichkeiten wie diese.
Funktioniert, vor allem wenn das so gemacht ist, dass das auch wirklich Kinder dazu animiert, da ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen.
Ich finde die Idee nicht schlecht.
Na toll, sind schon da.
Erstmal, erstmal Quicksync implementieren, nicht Quicksync, was sag ich, Quicksort.
Erstmal ein Quicksort programmieren mit Ifs.
Lasse, Jungs.
Kindergarten, gehst du rein, sagst Jungs, erst wenn ein funktionierender Quicksort da ist, geht die Tür wieder auf.
Ihr dürft erst heim, wenn ihr mir mal ein tausend, tausend Dings, Arrays sortieren könnt.
Sonst gibt es kein Mittagessen und ihr dürft nicht heim.
Erstmal Quicksort implementieren.
... oder Barrieren. Der Himmel ist das Limit.
Der Ifs ist ein educatives, soziales und kooperatives Projekt, das sich um die kleinen Mädchen und Jungs,
die sich bereit machen, ihre eigenen Zukunft zu kreieren.
Wir brauchen deine Hilfe, um diese kleine Familie zu leben.
Ich finde die Idee nicht schlecht.
Es ist durch deinen Unterstützung, dass wir den Kindern helfen können,
alles zu werden, was sie sich vorstellen können.
Wir wollen, dass die Kinder stoppen, nur Technologien zu benutzen und zu werden...
Das setzt aber eine Sache, warum das in Deutschland nicht funktioniert.
Wir haben keine Leute, die den Kindern das zeigen können.
Weil einfach den Kindern das hinschmeißen und sagen, macht mal,
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so interessant.
Da müssen auch ein bisschen Leute dabei sein, die selbst einen Plan davon haben.
Und haben wir in Deutschland nicht.
Wen haben wir denn im Kindergarten oder in der Vorschule, der programmieren kann?
Gibt's doch nicht.
... die Kreatoren des Weltkommens.
Was? Schau mal, Link.
Ein Reddit-Beitrag zu S.A.S.D. Okay, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Finde ich nice. Finde ich nice. Also, hat er... gefällt mir. Gefällt mir.
Ähm...
Okay, es gibt einen Reddit-Beitrag zur S.A.S.D., die wir uns vorher angeguckt haben.
Kickstarter-Scam-Warning.
Impossible Small S.A.S.D.
Ihr könnt doch einfach auf mich hören.
Das erste, was ich gesagt habe. Vor allem für den Preis, ja?
Also, it can not be done. Ja.
Ja, passt halt nicht rein.
Scamas, Leute.
Scammed. Scammed.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Big Light for Small Spaces.
Das sieht cool aus. Könnte ich für meinen Technikraum gebrauchen.
We believe that simplicity is the ultimate expression of beauty.
We believe that a truly beautiful device becomes so integrated into a person's life
that it disappears into the background.
Over time, that person notices only the absence of their device, not its presence.
Illumination. Light is...
Ja, ihr macht es halt noch philosophischer. So nach dem Motto, ja, wir bauen ein Licht.
Wir bauen ein Licht. Und jetzt kommt es an. Illumination. Die Quelle allen Lebens.
Hm, das Universum. Was auch immer. Zeigt halt einfach euer Ding.
Also, das Produkt, nicht euer Ding.
Fundamental to how we experience our environment.
So, what's it like working with Davey?
Davey is...
Was juckt mich das?
So, what's it like...
Mir wurscht, wie das ist, mit dem zusammenzuarbeiten. Mich interessiert, was da immer in der für ein Produkt rauskommt.
What's it like working with Davey?
Davey is...
Maybe a little dramatic.
Think about illumination forever.
It's strongly believed that once you see it, you'll never want to be without it.
We call it...
Luminuk.
Luminuk is a revolutionary new lighting solution for your home, and it's unlike anything you've ever seen before.
The Luminuk experience starts with a control module, powered by a removable lithium-ion battery pack.
This control module contains a suite of sensors that determines the position of the closet door,
ambient light conditions, and even the physical presence of the user.
Behind the scenes, the Luminuk control module is mounted inside the closet,
and powers a brilliantly bright LED strip that traverses the entire closet.
Das kann ich aber auch mit dem ESP32 und der LED-Lichterkette machen.
Ich meine, ich zeige euch mal was.
Wobei, ich muss euch nicht zeigen, ich habe euch meinen Weihnachtsbaum gezeigt.
Mein Weihnachtsbaum konnte das auch.
Und da war mit 15 Euro Hardware gebaut.
Ich meine, okay, der LED-Strip von meinem Weihnachtsbaum, der ging bis hier.
Ja, da hätte ich ihn halt noch viermal verlängern müssen.
... in einer Tür, die festgehalten und spezialisiert gehalten wird.
Eines der tollsten Designfehler von Luminuk ist, dass die Installation in weniger als 10 Minuten erledigt werden kann,
ohne besondere Fähigkeiten oder Werkzeuge.
Und für die Noobs ist das gut.
Ja, wo kommt denn das Licht her?
Der stellt das da unten hin, und wo kommt das Licht her?
Das Licht wird ja da jetzt nicht rauskommen, dass es oben...
Wie soll das Licht von da unten oben auf den Schrank leuchten, von oben?
... in weniger als 10 Minuten erledigt werden kann, ohne besondere Fähigkeiten oder Werkzeuge.
Einmal installiert, ist es fast komplett aus der Sicht versteckt.
All das resultiert in brillantem, lichtfreien Illumination, das vorher in einem geschlossenen Raum unmöglich war.
Wie fandest du deine erste Erfahrung mit Luminuk?
Der redet... der redet schon so erhaben, oder? Erhaben trifft's da doch richtig.
Ja, unser neues Produkt, das ist so unglaublich, wie das... die Welt um dich herum und so...
Der redet schon voll abgehoben irgendwie, so... so erleuchtet redet er, erleuchtet.
Die Sekte um das fliegende Spaghetti-Monster hat jetzt übrigens geklagt, dass sie als Religionsgemeinschaft anerkannt werden.
Luminuk hat Features, wie z.B. variablen Farbtemperaturen und Do-Not-Disturb-Mode, die den Benutzern die Möglichkeit geben, ihren Raum diskret zu besorgen.
Luminuk kann sogar mit einem hohen CRI-LED-Strip zusammengefasst werden, das natürliches Sonnenlicht mimiziert,
um dir die Unterschiede zwischen den schwarzen und grünen Schuhen in deinem Schlauch zu erzählen.
Luminuk ist so viel mehr...
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist es nicht.
Das ist... es geht überhaupt nicht um Beleuchtung, sondern um ein Gerät, wo man Beleuchtung mit steuern kann.
Ja, genau. Es geht nämlich überhaupt nicht um das eigentliche Licht.
Das kann ich mit dem ESP 230 anmachen für... für 5... 5 Euro.
Du kannst es nicht prädikten, wie viele du hast.
Die spawnen einfach bei dir im Schrank.
Stell dir mal vor, du stellst einen Luminuk unten in die Küche und auf einmal oben steht im Schrank steht auch noch einer.
Ist er einfach da.
Und wird natürlich abgebucht.
Ach du Scheiße!
Meine Fresse! Jetzt tragen sie aber dick auf, ey!
Jetzt! Jetzt!
Fuck, Alter! Jetzt haben sie aber dick aufgetragen!
Ich dachte, das ist eine schöne Lampe, die man irgendwo in die Ecke klatscht und dann macht sie immer schön hell.
Nee, ist es nicht.
Luminuk.
Oh, die Next Google hier. Next Google.
Leider noch nicht finanziert.
Das ist ein Stock-Image, oder?
Das ist ein Stock-Image, Alter.
Das ist ein Stock-Image. Der hat sich ein Stock-Image gesucht mit Inside drauf und hat das Ding dann Inside genannt.
Creating a search any similar to Google.
Besser als Google. Besser als Google.
Und das ist... das ist doch niemals der Typ. Niemals.
Das ist ein Stock-Foto.
Der Dude da drauf auf dem Bild.
Was für ein Schwachsinn.
Get your photos sent to... Warum?
Create your own brain to compute...
Langsam wird es aber immer abgetreten, oder?
Environnement.
Ah, es ist französisch. Dann ist es kein...
Dann ist es...
Keine Ahnung, wie man das so französisch ausspricht.
Create your own computer.
Doch, schon wieder.
Wir waren da oben doch schon.
Ah, das ist das Gleiche.
AR, VR, MA...
Can be magic.
Äh... ähm...
My Grill!
Endlich!
MA, ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab jetzt Machine Learning, aber kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Vielleicht kann es helfen...
Nein, ne?
Ja, das ist ja...
Irgendwas.
Das ist etwas außergewöhnliches...
Was ist denn mit Machine Learning?
Was war das?
Wer hat das?
Äh...
Was ist denn mit Machine Learning?
sich einfach einfach einfach ein paar ordentliche lautsprecher hinstellen und die hören sich dann
auch dass das braun magic toilet pro das braun ja was haben wir sonst noch ja alles nicht so
spannend aquarium automation gut habe ich keine verwendung zu magnetic wireless power bank
portable bettel magnetic power bank bestimmt ist bestimmt super zu bedienen wenn da hinten
so eine power bank dran pappt online virtual desktops was was möchtet ihr uns sagen erst mal
video was ich im keller aufgenommen das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch das lese ich mir nicht wir
gucken uns lieber das create your own brain computer interface an kennst du snips ai max
ja kann man nicht mal verwenden
leider war ganz gut peinliche affe ich habe nicht das problem mit dem video sondern dass
der irgendwie das video hätte ich mir sogar noch hätte ich mir sogar noch gegeben aber
der text what the fuck übertreib halt
brain controller
es komplett
messe
ich habe das so
er
diferencia
da Они footballing games
man nggak dannought games
die games workforce games zu kontrollieren ist es ist es ist schon mit mit händen
und so nicht so ohne und jetzt soll ich das mit dem hirn machen bei ihm weil Douglas unter deinen vr headset an
sehr toll das war etwas verschiedenes im video aber immer die anderen wir studierten sogrund der vr zu spokenoms
dass sowas geht brauchen tut in diesem stadium eigentlich kein mensch hat das bestimmt voll
anstrengend schwachsinn also jetzt leute magic toilet pro er braucht noch viele bäcker und da
sind nur noch vier tage übrig huge video erstmal schöne schöne portemonnaie ausgepackt was ist das
warum ist das video hochkant also warum ist das video hochkant und quer kennt sie dabei
hast moment moment ich muss mich mal kurz auf die seite legen vielleicht da kenne ich dann ja
hier da da sind kabel magic toilet das sieht halt leute wisst ihr was das ist
Wisst ihr, was das ist?
Ich erkenne, was das ist.
Das ist ein Ultrasonic-Sensor.
Das da ist das.
Hier.
Das ist ein Ultraschallsensor.
Seht ihr es?
Das sind drei Ultraschallsensoren nebeneinander.
Oder?
Ja.
Das sind drei Ultraschallsensoren nebeneinander.
Das braucht man zum Abstand erkennen.
Ich vermute mal, dass er das so macht,
dass er hier mit Abstand erkennt
und dann irgendwie hieran erkennen will,
in welche Richtung.
Deswegen musst du die auch weglaufen.
Wenn du aufstehst und bleibst davor stehen,
dann spült er nicht.
Aber wenn du irgendwie mitbekommst,
du entfernst dich,
dann spült er.
Dafür sind bestimmt die Ultraschallsensoren da.
Dass du es nach links mitkriegst,
Mitte kriegst und rechts.
Jede automatische Spülung funktioniert so.
Ja, aber nicht selbst gebaut mit einem
3D-gedruckten Gehäuse,
einem Arduino oder so drinnen
und ein bisschen Zeug.
Wozu braucht man das jetzt?
Ja, dass Vögel in deiner Toilette fliegen.
Pa!
Die Musik ist ja geil, Alter.
Pass mal auf.
Pa!
Okay, das Video war jetzt schon ziemlich schlecht.
Alter, muss man ja aufpassen hier.
Muss man ja aufpassen, dass nicht gleich hier
der P.I.P.
PedoBär anrückt.
Wer weiß, was man...
Ich trau mich gar nicht weiter,
das Video weiterzumachen.
Was leucht...
Ach du...
Was leuchtet da eigentlich so?
Guck mal, läuft...
Ist da irgendeine Sirene im Hintergrund?
Guckt euch mal die Wand an.
Warum flimmert die Wand so?
Kamera vielleicht.
Also, ehrlich Leute,
ganz, ganz ehrlich,
sowas könnten wir auch selbst bauen.
Ohne Probleme.
Controller haben wir alle da
Sensoren haben wir auch da
Dann holen wir uns noch den Ananas-Stepper
Jetzt weiß ich auch, wozu wir den Ananas-Stepper brauchen
Den Ananas-Stepper brauchen wir, um die Klospülung zu drücken
Oder wir holen uns den Finger-Bot
Der drückt dann für uns die Klospülung
Magic Toilet Prom
Ich glaube, das ist von jemand
Der meint das
Der bastelt gerne
Und der meint das halt auch wirklich
Ernst und ist davon überzeugt
Er hat aber halt keine Marketing-Agentur
Die das schön aufbereitet für ihn
Das einzige Problem
Was ich jetzt daran sehe ist
Du kannst halt keinem wirklich erzählen
Sich so ein Ding aufs Klo zu stellen
Niemand stellt sich so ein Ding aufs Klo
Wenn es dann in der Musik macht
Hier gibt es noch ein bisschen bessere Auflösung
Das sind Ultraschall-Sensoren
Das Ding sieht dann auch noch
Richtig schön designt aus
Sag doch mal hier
Ultrasonic-Sensor
Wer hat es gesagt, Leute?
Wer hat es gleich erkannt?
Huge
Manchmal zahlt sich das doch aus
Da ich ein bisschen mit so Krams rumbastel ab und zu
Predicted
Die Prediction
Ich dachte, es kommen noch ein paar
Person detected
Ready to fly
Das sind drei Ultraschall-Sensoren
Da ist irgendein Controller-Sensor
Und ein Elektro-Sensor
Das könnten wir ohne Probleme selbst machen
Word Arts
Oh Mann
Der Ananas-Stepper
Social Scope
Die Oma lernt
VI?
Ach nee
Ich dachte, das ist ein Lernprogramm für meine Oma
Dass sie VI bedienen kann danach
Danach kommt Wim
Smart Brain Training
Okay, da ist jetzt schon ziemlich viel Shit auf einmal dabei
Gehen wir noch mal hier auf die
auf die Gadgets
auf die Gadgets-Entdecker
Gucken wir auf da noch was drin ist
Was wir noch nicht hatten
Hatten wir alles schon?
LED-Touchlamp
Ohne Kabel
Okay, welche Features brauche ich bei einer kabellosen Lampe?
Welche Features brauche ich bei einer kabellosen Lampe?
Ein An-Aus Schalter
Vielleicht ein Helligkeitsregler.
Kann man...
Also das ist sowas, was man easy
sich basteln kann. Was man aber nicht basteln will.
Und einen großen Akku.
Ja. Gucken wir mal.
Kappa?
Ach Kappa.
Kuppa.
Nicht Kappa.
Golden Kappa Check.
Ähm.
Kappa.
Weil ich jeden Tag
meine Lampen umstelle.
Es ist ganz schön dunkel, oder?
Guckt mal.
Guckt mal auf den...
Der hat das gerade an- und ausgeschaltet
und du siehst fast nichts.
Guck mal.
Seht ihr irgendwas auf dem Tisch?
Da ändert sich...
Da ändert sich nichts vom Licht.
Guck mal auf dem Tisch.
Als wäre es nicht an.
Ah.
Das tut ja weh.
Da kann ich auch einfach ein Kabel dran machen.
WTF?
12 Stunden für eine Lampe.
Dann machst du zwei Abende an oder ein Abend an und das Ding ist leer.
Also mathematisch gesehen habe ich mit sowas immer Probleme.
Wenn da steht 10 Minuten gleich 2 Stunden.
Das ist falsch.
Sie meinen damit, dass man in 10 Minuten 2 Stunden lädt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ähm.
Kappa kann last for 2 hours.
Ich denke für 12.
Ja was denn jetzt?
2?
Oder 12?
Hä?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Es dauert nur 2 Stunden ohne nur 2 Minuten zu laden.
Crap, ne?
Crap.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Gleich.
Gleich ausgemacht.
Ja.
Weg.
Eliminiert.
Hatten wir alles schon?
Okay.
Dann sind wir jetzt nochmal besonders...
Was?
Nano Rain.
Ah für die Scheibe.
Ja dann gucken wir uns mal an was gerade besonders beliebt ist.
Hatten wir?
Hatten wir auch?
barrierclip
Das war...
Br características die wissen wir werden gleich verdreht damit da los gehts
Lasst es euch butchereterminiert
Ich dachte das könnte der habe ich schon Tenemos so Abgedrehte
vagg defence
Land
Da
donc
und
das
di
und
Das ist ja auch so easy.
Man lernt einfach mal nebenbei programmieren
und schreibt es dann in seine Bewerbung rein.
Erstmal der Mammut am Start.
Ja, aber wenn ihr so geile Kurse und Tutorials habt,
damit verdient ihr ja sicherlich auch Geld.
Warum braucht ihr da einen Kickstarter?
Alles!
Da habt ihr...
Alles, da habt ihr...
Sachen, die miteinander relativ wenig zu tun haben,
aber sportlich, sportlich, sportlich, ja.
Heute werden wir HelloCoding 2.0 herausfinden.
Das ist die neue und verbesserte Version von HelloCoding.
Was hat HelloCoding 2.0?
Es enthält alle tollen Informationen,
wie man ein Web-Developer, ein App-Developer,
ein Game-Developer werden kann
und wir werden ein Haufen Python- und Maschinenlern-Tutorials
machen.
Ich muss halt dazu sagen, dass Python für Maschinen-Learning ist gut,
für Game-Development so gut wie nicht, kaum verbreitet.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass man in Python keine Games machen kann,
aber welche Games fallen mir ein, die in Python sind?
Nicht viele.
Keine, um ehrlich zu sein.
Und Apps machst du auch nicht in Python normalerweise
und Webseiten auch nicht.
... Tutorials.
This is gonna be the last coding course you need.
In addition, a lot of tutorials just simply copy...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, man kann sich einfach einen Udemy-Kurs oder sowas holen.
Der kostet 15, 15, 15 Euro, hat 35 Videos
und man kann danach Python halbwegs, wenn man auch mitmacht.
... A to B.
Our tutorials show...
Okay, es ist wirklich Python, ja.
... show you how to make practical projects that you can use on your LinkedIn...
Unreal.
... or your resume.
Aber nicht mit Python.
... after selling 700,000 courses, we've listened to our customer base
and this is exactly what you've been telling us.
We understand that the best way to help people out in their career
is to give practical projects.
Employers are looking for people who can perform
and our tutorials are the best way to do that.
So we need your help to make an amazing bundle of courses.
You can check out all...
Blödsinn.
Wollen wir nicht.
An incredible tiny Arduino-kompatible...
... compatible...
Da bin ich immer interessiert dran, was es da so gibt.
Was ist denn das für eine Münze?
Irgendein Penny oder so, oder eine UK-Währung.
... meet Atto.
An incredibly tiny Arduino-kompatible...
Oh, Peter von Microsoft.
... that is designed for makers and is smaller than a USB-Plug.
It's on-board USB-capable...
Oh, das ist aber wirklich...
Oh, das ist wirklich klein.
Das ist cool.
Das ist wirklich klein.
Man kann sogar noch Pins anlöten.
Das ist Absicht, dass die nur so halb sind.
Gibt es ein paar Sachen.
Das ist echt ziemlich klein.
Es gibt kleinere Arduinos.
Also, mir fällt zumindest jetzt keiner ein.
Ja doch, es gibt die ATtiny-Dinger und sowas.
Aber es kommt darauf an, was drin ist.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Atmel, irgendwie 015-Arduino-Ding.
Aber das ist doch ordentlich klein.
... allows you to control your computer by simply using gestures or capacitive touch inputs.
What?
To produce music by using the ATTO as a MIDI-Device to control Ableton Live 10.
Moment, ich denke, es geht um ein Arduino-Board.
Ich kann damit alles Mögliche machen, was ich machen kann.
Single-sided design along with castellated holes allows you to build very interesting projects
like this RGB-LED-Coaster to make that cup of tea or coffee...
Das kann ich auch mit jedem anderen Controller, da brauche ich ihn nicht so klein.
Ja, die Specs interessieren mich auch.
... and yes, the ATTO can also be used the same way with protoboards, because why not?
Ja, klar.
Here's why we built yet another Arduino-Development-Board.
We recently started creating DIY-Project-Videos on our YouTube-Channel,
and almost all our ideas revolved around using sensors, displays and modules that are tiny.
Das ist ein ganz normaler DHT-11, das ist ein ganz normales SSD-1306.
Also im Prinzip, das ist ganz normales 015.
Wir sind aber schon viel kleiner geworden.
Acceleration-Sensor, glaube ich.
Das ist ein normales Arduino.
Wir sind aber schon viel kleiner geworden.
Davon habe ich mir mal ein paar bestellt, die sind abartig zu programmieren.
Da musst du voll über zig Hürden springen.
Ja, dann zeig mal, was dein Board kann.
Zeig mal, was dein Board kann.
Es ist ja schon wirklich klein, das ist gut.
WLAN? WLAN? Kein WLAN, oder?
Wenn es WLAN hätte, würde man die Antenne hier drauf sehen irgendwo.
Kein WLAN ist schon mal ziemlich doof, muss man sagen, weil WLAN ist so omnipräsent heute.
Es gibt Anwendungszwecke ohne WLAN, man kann natürlich da vielleicht noch irgendwie einen RF-Controller dran machen,
aber deswegen sind die ESPs auch so toll, die gibt es auch in ziemlich klein und haben halt immer WLAN.
Ja, okay.
Hat Hightechs viele Pins, das ist schon mal in Ordnung.
Ja, gut.
Der Design hat sich finalisiert und wir haben bereits die Supply Chain in Ordnung, um...
Ja, es ist ein kleiner Arduino.
Frage ist jetzt nur, Stromverbrauch? Stromverbrauch wäre sehr interessant.
WLAN gibt es keins, das ist schon mal doof.
Aber Deep Sleep Stromverbrauch, das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste bei so einem Ding.
Geht da irgendwie was?
Ja, er ist ziemlich langsam.
Er hat auch nicht gerade viel Flash.
Man darf nicht vergessen.
So eine ESP2866, wenn ich da eine Firmware kompiliere, ist die teilweise schon 2,5 MB oder so.
Oder war es 1,5?
Hängt der Verbrauch nicht einfach vom Microcontroller ab.
Nicht nur.
Das Ding hat zum Beispiel einen USB dran.
Der zieht...
Wahrscheinlich zieht der Spannungswandler für den USB mehr...
Pass auf, dass du nicht auf den Suchverlauf gehst.
Welchen Suchverlauf?
What?
10 Watt!
Willst du mich verarschen?
10 Watt, das ist der Witz.
Vielleicht...
Nein, nein.
Das Ding braucht...
Das Ding braucht ein paar Milliampere.
Das sind 3,3 Volt, ein paar Milliampere.
Aber die Dinger brauchen nichts.
Also der Spannungswandler USB ist die Frage, ob der ausgeschaltet wird im Deep Sleep und sowas.
So ein Board sind 5 Volt Board übrigens.
Ja, 0,3.
Die Dinger brauchen nichts.
Die brauchen nicht viel.
Aber nix ist immer noch zu viel auf Batterie und Deep Sleep.
Nix.
Alles ist zu viel für...
Also deswegen...
Und wir reden bei Deep Sleep geeigneten Boards nicht von Milliampere, sondern von Mikroampere.
Dass es halbwegs lange an der Batterie läuft.
Das Ding darf im Deep Sleep 10, 20 Mikroampere brauchen.
Wenn ich das jetzt Mist erzähle.
Dann hält es ein Jahr oder so an der Batterie.
Aber leider redet da nix zu Power-Consumption.
Power.
Hat das überhaupt eine gescheite Möglichkeit?
Man kann das noch nicht mal ordentlich per Batterie betreiben, sehe ich gerade.
Man kann das noch nicht mal ordentlich per Batterie betreiben, weil...
Das ist ein 5 Volt Board.
Die normalen Akkus, die haben vollgeladen 4,2 Volt und gehen dann immer weiter runter.
Aber...
Deswegen brauchst du eigentlich...
Boards, die mit 3,3 laufen.
Und halt auch ein bisschen mehr aushalten.
Hat das keine 5 Volt und Crown Pins?
Doch!
Aber dein Akku nicht.
Dein normaler Akku...
Die normalen Batterien...
Nicht Batterien.
Die normalen Akkus, die du dafür nimmst.
Die haben vollgeladen 4,2 Volt.
Und die droppen dann runter, je nach Entladungsstand.
Das heißt, damit kannst du das Ding schon mal gar nicht betreiben.
Zumal es wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht geht, dass ich einen Pin als Input verwende.
Oder war es 3,7?
Nee, ich glaube 4,2 vollgeladen.
Hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt.
Sah interessant aus, das Projekt, aber ich habe jetzt wenig Anwendungszwecke für...
Wann bin ich denn jetzt schon on?
Oh, dreieinhalb Stunden!
WTF.
Professional Lighting for Everyone.
Das ist gut für mich.
Das ist gut.
Das wäre gut für mich.
Da kann ich ordentliche Aufnahmen machen.
3,7.
Ja, dann ist es 3,7.
Aber voll 3,7.
Genau, 3,7.
Shoot, Scheinwerfer!
Ah ja.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Ob das was taugt?
Ist alles USB?
Warum nicht?
Ja Leute, war doch ganz interessant.
Also mir reicht es jetzt.
Ich muss in einer halben Stunde um euch pennen.
Wir gehen morgen wieder aufstehen.
Ähm.
Gibt es so irgendwas, was ihr loswerden wollt?
Irgendwas, was ihr wissen wollt?
Ah ja, ja.
Guck mal, ob es irgendwelche Leute gibt, die ich horsten kann.
Äh, nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich.
Nee.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns dann die Tage.
Macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
C U.